I have some new tour dates to announce I
will be in Grantville PA
on July 19th that's Pennsylvania at Penn
Heroes stage at Hollywood Casino
pre-sale starts this Wednesday June 7th
at 10 A.M Eastern with code Rat King
General on sale begins Friday June 9th
at 10 A.M Eastern we're also announcing
a sixth Toronto show on August 19th at
the Elgin Theater tickets for that show
are on sale now
we also have tickets remaining for
Austin Texas June 11th Edmonton Alberta
July 14th Guilford New Hampshire July
20th Windsor Ontario August 18th and
Niagara Falls
Ontario August 20th get all your tickets
through theovan.com
t-o-u-r I'm so thankful to you guys for
coming out and spending time
check out our classic merch with the
racing hunting and fishing collections
we also have the classic rat tea the I'm
upstairs
gear and more head over to
theovonstore.com today to take a look
today's guest is uh is one of the most
entertaining men on social media
um he's been here before
I love getting to spend time with him he
has his studio right upstairs from ours
and um and it's just great to know that
there's such good Creative Energy in the
building he has his stiff socks podcast
uh he tours and he's one of the most
creative young men in the game uh
today's guest is Mr Trevor Wallace
[Music]
games
[Applause]
Kelly Rowland baby Kelly Rowland we
rolling
rolling they hate Chamillionaire he's
like an investor now dude Chamillionaire
um
Chamillionaire was a
he had a studio by our first student he
had a office in our first Studio what
was he doing in there in the same
building
he was just chamill and I got or
whatever I don't know what they do you
know what I'm saying yeah he's last I
saw he's just a big investor in a bunch
like business [__] yeah he wasn't in the
trenches anymore you know he wasn't no
no no no no you know what the trenches
are I've heard of them yeah now I grew
up in a suburb we never like we we wish
we were in trenches really we always
thought we were in a gang but like
nobody like would check us like that's
how you know in your suburban like you
could just say you're in a gang and
everybody all right like nobody was like
which one people would just be like oh
me too man by the time you guys meet we
had a meeting time for a game yeah after
math on Tuesday yeah yeah like if your
mom picks you up from the gang it's not
really exactly right right and then she
offers a ride to everybody else do you
need a ride home Riley oh your mother's
coming she's a sweetheart
mom we call him Gunner
you know she's not even using people's
code name right right yeah and then when
your mom walks away you look back
I used to cuss my mama tell Dad did you
ever cuss at parents I used to cuss him
all the time no I think
um we would sometimes spray paint
obscenities and stuff on my mom's car I
remember
huh like big words are just like kind of
small no just things like or whatever
like things that didn't even really
relate to her it was just would people
honk be like I'm with you I mean I don't
know what people like some people I
think showed up there at night like
thinking it was like a club or whatever
like you sometimes you go out in the
middle and I had to be a couple gay
dudes out there yeah yeah people are
knocking on the Windows be like where do
I venmo where do I vote yeah we had a
spray paint that was like meant for just
like like art but it washed off so you
could spray paint somebody's car and
then they'd lose their mind but then
they'd rub right off oh that's sick it
was fun yeah yeah they had this thing
bust people would put uh they put like a
sliced meat or something on somebody's
car at night oh a shark oh baloney yeah
pin off a car yes they have like a Honda
Civic rolling around with just smallpox
on it it looked like somebody had done
cupping on the back yeah yeah yeah yeah
on the hood all right damn that's
something's really working on itself
it's the core you know
it was right yeah it seemed like yeah
it's like God about that oh yeah and you
somebody if you really hated somebody
you put three or four slices on them I
mean you would charcuterie up a damn uh
the front of a Ford Escort oh yeah if
you hated somebody in the area right you
know they [__] you just then the
birds would pull up and be like oh [__]
we got a charcuterie board right here
yeah yeah I mean there was one there was
one that would like turn somebody's
grass a different color you throw like
Cheerios in it or do you ever do forking
where you put a plastic forks in
somebody's lawn and you snap the handle
that was most [__] up because just
break a lawnmower oh really you break it
and then at the top you break the handle
so you can't really get them out we were
just bored and didn't have drugs yeah it
sounds like a very
low risk gang yeah yeah did y'all have a
name or anything for the gang or not I
don't
I just remember the initials were TFE I
don't remember what it stands for
[__] English or something I don't
really know what it was there's
definitely a [__] in there you like
yeah when I found out the F4 the first
time I said it to my dad I called him a
[__] head I didn't know I knew the power
of [__] but I didn't know how to use it
oh yeah so my dad said something and I
was walking away from the table on my
way out I was like whatever you [__]
and then I just heard the belt coming
off oh yeah you just hear the the
fondling with it yeah and I was like oh
boy then you run to your room it's like
he knows where you're at that's the
worst thing you only had one place to go
and you're cornered yeah
papa no
but no dude yeah it sound like uh that
sounds like a fairy we got almost what
century was it uh the early 90s okay
early 90s papa no sound kind of but I
just try to make a connection so he
wouldn't hurt me oh yeah father yeah
father it's his eye yeah your loving son
if I made a connection maybe it wouldn't
hit me as hard yeah father it's not
meant to be father it's me your
dementia's kicking in yeah it's a good
old pal Trev do you want to be in the
Gang
yeah I remember one time my mom uh broke
a paddle over my ass and I started
laughing your parents really abused yeah
they would uh spank you yeah yeah oh
yeah he was a classic white family but
like they would do that and then they
would be like I'm only doing this
because I love you yeah [__] hit me
talk some [__] you know don't don't
throw some soliloquies as a haiku poem
yeah it is I guess I think the thing
about running to the room that is such
the because as a parent you have to be
like how dumb is this kid they ran to
the only place and it's the same thing
you did as a kid you're like how have we
not learned I think that that was like
our safety it's like I'm in my room you
can't you can't get in here yeah it's
like watch me
we don't have any locks on the doors you
didn't I had to jerk off just with uh
with the safety off every night just
with God was your lock yeah just hold on
and what I and the light used to crack
through the door so I'd be oh I'm going
to bed I'm gonna touch myself so I go to
bed and then I put a towel most people
do is to hide like smoke from weed but I
wasn't cool so I put the towel under the
door crack so the light wouldn't shine
through because I was messing that
freaking rub baby smoking that [__] just
in case you were freaking yeah in case
you just did it so well you just started
native and out and yeah exactly they
knew what was going on
did armor went off have you ever laid on
your back and put your legs in the air
while you jerked off that's like a
[__] thing you could do I'm never I
would never do that it sounds like you
might have done that I haven't done that
you want to no I don't want to do that
dude that's great wait so you're saying
this guy's teeth
when would you ever need to be in that
position you're laying on your back and
your feet are in the air I don't know
right there yeah I just remember seeing
this very alarming like drawing or
something on a
website uh it could have been on a
website or even like this side of like a
dumpster which was like an early website
oh yeah like before they had websites
people would like write message for help
on a dumpster you know of course that is
true you know like my son's gay like on
a dumpster cycling or yard waste neither
it's for my son can you pick what
position you get a colonoscopy in
oh well I've wondered about I mean you
know and I've long thought that a lot of
misbehaving children or kids that are
really bad were born doggy style I've
heard that I feel like that what's the
most like wholesome missionary
probably just jerk off into your hand
and give it to her like however you want
to insert this into you oh that's very
that's like a Valentine's Day yeah yeah
yeah that's a good old school
Valentine's where people walk thousands
of miles to get it there the seed right
yeah here you go post mates Postmates
for Cheryl
if you were to have a kid what position
would you want it to be
um what's it called when you uh
um conceived yes well that oh that was
that was what I thought I thought years
ago and I've long thought that children
conceived in doggy style positions are
more likely for that makes sense things
like cry dog in them
um yeah they got yeah they just yeah
little Labradoodle
something about it yeah I think if you
throw it yeah I mean the kind of kid why
their parents are making love you
[__]
if a frizzy goes past and the semen in
there just kind of runs to one side of
her body that's that dog baby that's a
dog right there you think what do you
think it was the the type of kid would
be if the girl's on top and then that's
how it's conceived you think the kid it
was like tall maybe a little like
posture good posture I definitely think
good posture straight I don't like
people who get posture it feels like
they know something that we don't well
it feels like they're working for
somebody yeah it feels like somebody
who's trying really hard to blend in to
be a human yes and like if you ask what
his name was he would know it he would
say like too quick yeah Rick yeah I'm
Rick it'd have a question mark yeah I'm
Robert Robert yeah when it's just like
this
I'm Rick
like they start like the it starts
glitch and afterwards like you didn't
get the update or whatever yeah like
he's probably trying to read Ebola
alphabet soup like he could really
quickly if he wanted to yeah yeah just
started yelling all the letters I'm Rick
I'm Rick I'm root and then he's like
starts like if you don't get the update
the guy gets gay or somebody's like I'm
Rick
like what how much does the update cost
because any update costs like 59.99
you're like well you could also like
hack updates but then if your son like
your good postured son
is now a gay son everybody's like oh you
can't afford to make your son straight
you won't get the update I think it'd be
more expensive to make your son gay I
think it's an upgrade to be gay yeah
that's true a better style you always
have energy you ever seen the gay dude
yawn uh
just always on dude I've never seen a
gay dude yawn they're just two pumps
they just got life they all also I just
I think you need a couple Gators in your
corner because they're just opinionated
they will give it to you straight like
like bro like just this like every dude
at Barstool like you could ask him a
question they'll be yeah I bet for sure
uh-huh but you can be oh is this good
outfit but yeah for sure but like a gay
dude will be like good outfit for what
dumpster diving and you're like right
that right there I need that in my life
right they'll put you in check right
yeah like fighting your stepdad yeah
yeah did you ever run away from your
parents when you're a kid oh dude I
remember
I ran away yeah I ran what would you
pack would you pack anything or use a
raw dog life I remember the second I was
born I remember being across the room
like you got shot put it out I mean I
ran away they're gonna steal because the
cord is still on oh dude I think I
remember tying the cord like the nurse's
foot just to like keep people locked up
like you're surfing like no this can to
confuse them you know oh really because
that thing's a [__] house arrest I
wonder how many babies think that's a
dong are they like damn I'm packing out
of the gate yeah and the doctor was like
ah now we gotta cut that one and then we
gotta cut the other one
yeah I don't know I do remember I
remember trying to run away man I
remember going to the post office
because I thought somebody could mail me
somewhere you're a light baby in our
town no I think when I was like probably
10 or something like 11 okay just rode
my bike over there and I remember
thinking that somebody could mail me
somewhere maybe not 10 maybe 11. with
the biker now I don't know I just
remember finally getting to the post
office it wasn't that far but it was
like maybe about five miles and I got
there and I was like
the first person that I saw that looked
nicer like concerned or whatever
somebody combed their hair I was like I
gotta get out of town where did you want
to go anywhere yeah that's funny just go
to the Post Office send me anywhere yeah
my dad had a friend who robbed a a bank
on a bike when he was 14. oh yeah which
is hilarious that's the same mentality
of running to your room when your
parents about to hit you you're like
where are you running to on a bike your
skate park I don't like Kmart isn't
really anywhere yeah but he got caught
he did yeah they just put a stick and
spoke oh I don't know how they caught
him but yeah dude I was a 14 year old on
a bike
like you're gonna get caught oh yeah
they had two they had two brothers in
our town they were they were Twins or if
they were uh
uh they weren't twins they were brothers
and uh uh they did a drive-by shooting
on a bike in our town
bear bear one of them named bear bear
and I don't know what the other one is
was it a tandem bicycle or they were
just riding next to each other a tandem
drive-by would be hilarious moody or
something maybe bear bear and Moody but
they were brothers and one of them was
on the handlebars yeah and he did the
shooting
oh on the handlebars yeah that's
honestly kind of cute I think it would
be so hard because like yeah the
blowback yeah and you're kind of already
balancing yourself up really that'd be
kind of tight oh that'd be sick how we
see that in the South where dudes all
just on a dirt bike or like Atlanta type
[__] let's do wheelies on just like on
dirt bike through town that makes me
feel uh you know good I like seeing that
well that's the new like the cavalry's
coming when you see a batch of like yeah
because you'll see something and that is
one of the most there must be something
about those those bike riding because
that is the most diversifying thing
people all ethnicities come together to
do those things the wheelies yeah that
is true I was just in Indianapolis over
the weekend there's a whole bunch of
that it's just just a red light and
somebody pulls up Bryant yeah sounds
loud as hell for no reason oh it's the
worst dude yeah I was out there at uh
garyvee con have you ever met Gary you
went to vcon yeah I went there to go uh
film a video yeah it's bizarre how what
yeah I talked to you yeah yeah yeah I
talked with Gary about it online but it
started once he it was named v-con to me
that was a it seemed a little
it made me kind of wonder what's going
on what am I getting involved it was
it's exactly picture of econ right now
that's it whatever you're thinking about
what are you thinking about
uh yeah like people bothering people
about money yeah it was a lot of like
bright colors and people who may have
not seen a tit in a while oh yeah I mean
look Gary's a very nice guy and he like
fires these people to [__] up the
funniest thing he said we watched his
speech on the last night and we walked
in at a random part and I walked in on
him going [__] your grandparents yeah
and I'm like that's the energy I need in
life like they are past R.I.P I love you
both but like [__] them you know like
that's just where he's at in life yeah
he and I I like uh oh I mean I totally
respect I respect his Acumen you know
yeah I think but he also like but he
tells people crazy [__] he'll be like
you know oh you gotta uh
like there's videos of him like meeting
a guy in a park and the guys like I sold
all of our silverware I sold yeah my
baby high chairs I sold everything I
made I made 720 you know it carries like
he like hugs him he's like that's great
the guy's like yeah we're not staying
we're living in this park we're cutting
down all costs and then it pans out and
him and his family are living in a
[__] park right yeah yeah and then
Gary's like you're doing wonderful kicks
it over and he goes That's from me to
you you got to start from the bottom to
be at the top and you were too humble he
talks like uh just like like a crazy
person in front of a 7-Eleven but he's
so convincing at it right like if you
walk past it got himself let me like
[__] your grandparents you'd be like
sure right I get that yeah but then you
get one of those tiny headsets like the
little like Ted Talk ones and I'm like
yeah you know what [__] them yeah I
agree he makes a lot of good points but
yeah it's just good stuff well I think
it's you all there's always people that
are giving like guidance and inspiring
people inspiring is nice because I think
it's hard to get inspired and so if
garyvee inspires you or whoever you find
that inspires you you know
um that's great no and he he was very
good at it he could say anything and you
put like enough of an emphasis or like
an exclamation point every couple words
in your hand yeah the guy's like are you
are you still using silverware he'll ask
me you're still using silver like I was
a guy and he's like you can sell you
could sell those you could easily sell
those silverware and be up 25 28 dollars
exactly you know yeah you have to put
food in your mouth with your hand yeah
you ever seen the videos of him going to
garage sales they're the funniest things
insane dude he's I mean he's almost he
has like 150 million to his name but
he'll go to a garage sale and be like
how much for this ficus tree and they're
like oh seven dollars and he goes I'll
give you four and they're like oh well I
mean
okay we really need it we just need a
liver transplant by Tuesday right it'll
do that and then he'll walk away and I'm
like [__] got him those are still
it's it's hilarious that was I made a
video about this because that's why we
got connected really um yeah I made a
video kind of just talking [__] how he
like literally just low balls poor
families in like Des Moines yeah
like he like hardballs them like he'll
walk up and like 100 bucks for this and
I'm like let me play hard to get goes
his car rips some K walks back and he's
like we'll do 68. okay please our son is
our son has one tooth he's been eating
applesauce out of it too for eight years
and he's like I'll give you three it's
it's electric I love your son yeah I
love that type of energy though good but
he also he was born like with why he was
like from a wine Fortune yeah so that's
the only thing like I'm not knocking it
but it's like
is it always has been has he always had
money like is it really I don't know uh
is it really if you don't have any money
I forget the backstory but I think there
was something where like he like started
the family business something with the
wine I don't really know what happened
but um
yeah I don't know dude he was convincing
as [__] and it's like you want to laugh
but then you leave there a little fired
up you ever been to a black church oh
yeah those get you fired up they're so
much better than regular Church they got
a drum set yeah I've been I'm Jewish um
but I want to like regular Church a few
times and I was like but I have to go
into a black church and then go and I
was like this [__] is boring oh dude
black church is definitely yeah you like
feel the Lord oh you feel the Lord and
somebody will Splash [__] hot grease
on your back you're in the middle of it
like you don't even know what's going on
like you don't know somebody just like
ripped open like a lunch plate real fast
ladies like whipped her hair yeah like
you'll see a black lady she'll have a
[__] plant she'll be watering a plant
in her hey during the [__] sermon
dude people are dressed up are you a
grape or something oh everybody smells
good dude the Lord will pass through the
room through that one point like I
wanted to give him I already donated but
I was like send it [__] back I want to
donate more oh yeah what's the bowl
whatever I don't know but this [__] it
was like three hours and and I mean man
it had an arc start out slow you feel
the closing bit then there's the grand
finale and I just want to throw my wall
in the damn air and be like I'm
converted and then just throw it up
there oh I'll throw up yeah yeah I'll
throw my [__] dick in the air and
catch it in my mouth dude
you know what I'm saying if if if it
calls for it but I'm like God calls for
if God calls for that if that's what
I've been in them the first funeral I
ever went to man was a black guy
he um
died he was the biggest guy in our town
his name was Ricardo buffer just kind of
large David's buff he was like uh a
man-child it was like as if you saw like
a nine-year-old child but he was like I
mean he's probably six four damn
and I bet he was nine he weighed two no
he looked like a nine-year-old but he
was probably I guess we were in
11 or 12. maybe he was six two six four
and he might have been six four he was
the biggest he was the biggest kid in
our town he was
oh you've never seen nothing like it
they didn't have it
you know when you see you should have
just been the mayor oh he would I mean
he definitely he could [__] keep the
sun off of you
he was [__] big I mean he [__] [__]
up in DodgeBall oh dude he was just he
could do whatever he want the birds knew
him the birds I mean you see a bird come
[__]
big dude
he was playing basketball it was like a
little league basketball game and I
think Big Boy Little League 11 and 12
year olds and uh he had a heart attack
die really was he was he all Natty or is
he on the roids he wasn't on anything he
was just on just too much I think he had
did his heart they said he had an
enlarged heart I don't know what that
means what does that means just the
heart of a grown man in a young boy's
body it could have been it I wish I had
a grown man's penis when I was 12. do
you kinda oh you don't want it just
because then I had that you had that or
you have it I had it as a child as a
child yeah did you know that yeah the
[__] would I know that I was born with
an adult's uh adult dog genital yeah
just damn ball and penis are just ball
or just penis I think it's the whole
thing wow so when did you know that like
when like when did you look down one day
and you're like oh I'm packing more than
the average oh I remember seeing other I
remember seeing some other kids like
wieners and not even noticing and then
my wiener I felt like looked like
Florida
and I was like oh damn dude like people
are gonna show up on my wiener like in
the summer yeah yeah you're like Alabama
in there too dog we're packing and I
just remember like just being so
uncomfortable yeah because um and I
remember sleeping at night and feeling
it under my body really and it was just
a nightmare do you have like talking in
and [__] too yeah it was embarrassing
embarrassing yeah cause you weren't the
same you were just abnormal no kid no
five-year-old's like yeah who's got a
big dick you know and if they ask that
they're definitely not five it's a 48
year old man on the internet who's big
dick also other five-year-olds enter
so did you grow into it or you just
steady packing no I just grew into it oh
wow but yeah I have some more
abnormality but let's look at that in
large heart I just want to know what
it's called in a large heart and a child
I've lost two friends actually to
basketball playing hard with anybody's
heart and in large heart cardio megaly
what is it Zack well it says it's
usually caused by another condition like
it's a side effect but it can be caused
by damage to the heart muscle or any
condition that makes the heart pump
harder than usual and then um Hearts
just be gone that's crazy every day he
working if he's never taking Labor Day
off it may also be a sign of a prior
heart attack
hmm does that run in the family I think
so heart attacks you isn't that crazy
when something runs in the family you're
just like you just have to like take
down the grain of salt but oh all right
breast cancer runs in the walls jeans
cool yeah oh my tits can men get breast
cancer don't clip this I don't know how
[__] the human body works would it
would it what do you mean like like can
men get breast cancer you can yes okay
do they call some chest cancer
I've got something I don't know what it
is you ever felt something in there
sometimes when I drink too much I feel
like I have it I'm like I don't know
where my liver is but I feel it beating
extra today
oh yeah if your liver is beating
then yeah you probably need to take it
in sometimes I just get pain in the
middle of my chest
and then I remember a girl's day one
time she's like oh it's heartburn I was
like is it
it's been three days I think it's just
like uh it could just be your [__]
signal you know what I'm saying like you
could we could just be a little bit IBS
I'll be [__] signal
right you got pain right there sometimes
dude yeah what happens when you wake up
is your body just good to go or you just
got pain no I think these days I [__]
want to vape or are you off The Vape
still go down on a stranger that's a
woman in what order
either one I think just you want
something to kind of get you going one
of the first porns I ever saw was a girl
smoking a cigar out of her [__] oh my
God yeah really yeah and it was like
what was it for it was like an advertise
was it a uh it might have been from
Marlboro but I remember I was just so
young I was just like I was turned on
for both reasons because I wasn't old
enough to smoke but I also wasn't old
enough to stroke come on now so I saw
the cigar and the vagina and I was like
those are both so cool yeah yeah it was
wild oh wow yeah because I feel like
there was always some kid who like like
you knew he would show you porn but then
the like his older brother would be like
yeah but you want to see that [__]
smoke a hookah like he had the next
level yeah yeah
you want to see this labia throw a
grenade like damn okay this lady is in a
hot tub making lasagna he's like oh you
want to see this uvula uh eat a half a
bag of Skittles you're like damn yeah I
don't but like I feel like one dude
always had the porn but like somebody
close to him had Next Level porn yeah
you want to see this urethra do a Zen
oh [__]
you know I was in a car accident
um four years ago
some lady did a u-turn and she didn't
know how to do it and she just
she you turned right into me it was more
of a j and I was at the end of the J
and I got just jacked up that's what
happened
if you're ever injured
in a car accident or injured at all and
in some type of accident you can check
out Morgan and Morgan
and Morgan is America's largest injury
Law Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars were
covered for clients Morgan and Morgan
has a proven track record of fighting
till you get your full and fair
compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer
with Morgan and Morgan you can submit a
claim without ever having to leave the
couch you might not be able to heck if
you're hurt if you're ever injured you
can check out Morgan and Morgan their
fee is free unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com
this past weekend or dial pound law
that's pound 529 from your cell phone
that's for the people.com
this past weekend or pound 529 from your
cell phone this is a paid advertisement
blue chew you know it you know when
daddy wants it he takes them blue cheesy
likes them little wiener Bears you know
that boy they deliver the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable form at a fraction of the cost
Bluetooth tablets combat all forms of Ed
so they can help
they can help men gain extra confidence
for when it's time to perform wiener
[Music]
don't like swallowing pills no problem
these are chewable
that's right and guys here's a special
deal for you try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code Theo at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's blue
chew b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com
promo code Theo to receive your first
month free
yeah I feel like
um
for whatever re like that was like drug
dealing back then was like it is like
yeah somebody somebody always had like
oh you know whenever you buy weed
they're like oh this is the best in town
some would always be like yo it's the
best porn you can find you know some
random website really you used to go you
could go to whitehouse.com and it was
porn because the White House was like
dot gov is like the official one but
like I'm you oh we got a head knot see
yeah
producers always know that poor in life
yeah that was like the oldest trick in
the book in like 2001. but that was so
cool because my parents just thought I
was doing homework every night exactly
they're like oh this [__] just
loves George Bush no I love being off to
Bush what are you talking about because
you could just go to whitehouse.com and
your parents wouldn't associate it too
wow see when I was a child they didn't
have uh
internet
so we had to you had to [__] get
somebody who knew something about some
cooter you had to [__] have somebody
tell you or somebody describe it yeah or
like you'd lay in the dark at night and
one guy his job was to kind of try and
make the sounds of like a vagina
so that other people could enjoy it you
know yeah yeah or like your boys were
doing a sleepover you know yeah of
course or like one of your boys buries
you at the beach and then you put sand
tits on you oh yeah you ever do that and
you put the two seashells over it so
it's like scandily clad yeah and then
you have a little sand like someone's
saying just starts to like Elevate above
your wiener
like damn brother but if you can move
Earth with your wiener like that's boy
that's positive my God I bet some dad
would look at him like that's my boy
that's the tectonic plates though like
is that the Earth just doing there it's
getting bricked up like when there's
earthquakes that the Lord's [__]
bricked yeah or just creating a vagina
or something bumping and grinding It's
gotta be huh so you didn't have internet
I feel like my early on porn days was
like girls gone wild like like do you
remember those commercials where the
girls would have the Stars over their
nipples I don't know what it was like we
had all seen yes it was like what would
be like we just needed to know what was
behind that star like we knew what a tit
looked like but I'm like I didn't know
what those look like and whatever
happened to that guy who created that
site Joe what's his name I think he's in
jail
yeah I heard that I think he actually
that are like probably Tucson or
something yeah Tucson which is basically
this outdoor jail
it's free play jail yeah it's like no
bars jail yeah it's like you you can
roam but do you want to you just stay at
this Chili's all day yeah dude I used to
go to I used to go to uh School in
Tucson man did you you went to dirty tea
I went to Santa Rita high school man for
one semester and people are always fist
fighting the car wash dog after school
you box dog you box that isn't we we did
bodybuilders at our school bodybuilders
no face shots oh really yeah so you
could just punch each other in the Torso
a bunch but no face oh it sounds like a
really tough game yeah dude that's what
we found the leader of our game but one
time our dark down a body was got hit in
the face and that was on me you took a
body blow in the face yeah yeah that was
on me though because I ducks that was a
[__] oh yeah dude I'm not tough at all
like I'm [__] and I'm really [__] if
you're a [__] dude it'll ruin it can
really it won't it can make things it'll
be interesting oh dude people knew I was
a [__] I was wearing really yeah
because I'd wear like Heelys with no
heels you know they'd be like what are
you wearing those dumbass shoes for you
can't even heal so the wheel on the back
but no wheel in it yeah no wheels just
an empty area like I was just like like
any time somebody's like you want to go
body blows I'll be like no please no I
don't want to do this we do Tech Deck
together yeah if you say please no
that's bad dude
dude I remember one time I uh
accidentally said I went to hit a guy on
the shoulder and he duck and I hit his
nose and he had any bloody nose and then
uh he kept [__] me all day in uh
science and then he's like this Saturday
we're gonna fight I'm bringing my
brother meet me there and I didn't show
up because obviously I didn't have an
older brother I had an older sister who
had a fat rack so I'm like what the [__]
am I supposed to do and then on Monday
he's like yo you didn't show up I'm like
yeah just let me just pencil in this ass
beating real quick
did you fight a lot growing up or well
one thing at a time one thing at a time
oh sorry what are we talking about um
Trevor Wallace is here oh yeah thank you
man yes yeah it's so it's fun it's fun
to see you bro
um he's still crushing it on socials I
don't see how you keep doing it I don't
know man but you keep doing it I'm
trying to it's amazing
um I want to get I want to find out
about this Joe guy and then we can oh
the guy from uh yeah yeah Girl's Gone
Wild yeah red checks out long story
short he filed for bankruptcy moved to
Mexico and their allegations that some
of those girls were underage so he's
kind of just floating it seems like wow
he looks like that and he's married to a
woman Abby Wilson I think they're
estranged according to this article
because there was a there was a big
expose on Girls Gone Wild last year I
believe so since then there's something
extra heat on what uh what does a
strange mean
um they don't like each other anymore oh
yeah separated from each other
so because yeah remember that was the CR
and that was like where kind of they had
like the girl it was almost like where
kind of bang bust started a little bit
wouldn't they have girls in the van or
something sometimes and like show your
tits and be like I don't want to but I
will in a minute right right and then
they show me they put the Stars over the
Stars I was like well sensor well yeah
that was like because now Tick Tock is
it's kind of that but without the tits
they just brought up to a hot girl and
be like what's your body count it's like
[__] all that put the stars on the tits
how do you pitch that idea you got to be
coked out as hell to go to your boy and
be like you still got that you still got
that camcorder I know
partying dude I've ran into girls who
who got on this who are on Girls Gone
Wild over the years like yeah I was on
girls going wild a while back you know
smoking out of their neck holes oh yeah
they're like yeah somebody [__] this
hole into my neck I would give a lung
problem like nah somebody just did sex
right into my neck like I just needed
more holes more ventilation put the drop
top in the throw yeah yeah for a
convertible right here would you put
that in there if you could just close it
without anybody noticing
yeah I think so yeah might as well I
think the human body should be upgraded
I'm like I gotta pee so much I'm like
how can I get more storage on my phone
but not a bigger bladder oh definitely I
need at least half a terabyte in one of
my legs for this piss
I also think my brain is at capacity oh
God because you got to kick out memories
from like fourth grade just to learn how
to parallel park at some point but
that's vital memories in fourth grade
you found out like National Geographic
had tits in it oh dude when we saw them
long they had a set of long darks in one
of those Geographic episode because it
was the first time you saw a black tit
in the area just a tit in general well
yeah there wasn't a lot of like first of
all the porn when I first saw it it was
very uh
it was like people like it was people
that had the same kind of haircut
kind of having sex from far away and
there was a lot of music in the
background you couldn't even really hear
the people yeah yeah so there was a lot
of like
they're so horned up you don't even know
if that music was from you or the TV
about it it was just but it wasn't
coming from there was a lot they did
more with the soundtrack back then like
they cared more about the music and the
Ambiance and went with it they set the
tone then like hearing what the people
were saying yeah and and then it evolved
um
so you get some of that but you had you
didn't have your phones you couldn't
just play porn wherever so if you went
outside or left the television or
whatever you were there was no porn yeah
at that point you had to see somebody
that could do some art or you'd have to
um you know we've talked about it before
but somebody had chiseled a set of uh
tits into a like a birch that have been
hit by light and just like half of a
tree by us oh that's correct and so
people would go out there and just cream
out to that and would you like try to
like hide the tree like you were to
clear your browser history like would
you try to like like undiscover it like
that way nobody else could see it maybe
somebody had like leaned a branch or
something just hide it from you know
because you don't want to like you want
to gate keep a little bit yeah that's my
porn yeah this is mine but you get back
there and you'd uh you could tell other
people had been back there there'd be a
cigarette or a half a can of uh beanie
Wayne or something oh yeah something
chiseled I came here 1993.
somebody just it was like a heart it was
just like Rick but it'd be like Rick
plus but also just Rick Rick plus Rick
Rick plus Rick dick
I feel like when we were younger you
didn't look for porn porn just found you
like you wouldn't be looking for like
you just open up a book and you're like
oh damn I got tits on page 48. what it
blew your I mean you would get porn
wherever you could like it in science is
sex ed was such a like people would
dress up I mean I were you know people
would wear their Sunday Best people wear
cologne to sexy you know be like yeah
you guys knew when it was well yeah you
knew the year that it was and you were
like God are we getting ready and I
remember people outside of the [__]
classroom like slapping each other in
the cheeks you notice one guy putting
ice on another guy's like neck and back
yeah you know it was crazy it wasn't
that guy when he learned tomorrow oh
[__] yeah like Mike Brown was his coach
it was like it was his like you had a
corner man really you know we get in
there we didn't get no like like lead up
to it it was just like all right class
get your dicks out it's sex that day
like there was no build up like we just
learned like we had no idea wow so they
just sprung it on us and then we'd have
to play it cool you know do you remember
the first time that you were attractive
to a woman
I do were you always the kid that was
like kind of got the girls some no I
never I never really got a lot of women
um I do remember the first time this
like the first girl that came back with
a rack after summer that was like God
that was big that was like when they
build a new like Tesla Charger station
in town you're like everybody knew about
it oh this girl Jamie she showed up in
sixth grade and she was rocked out and
like it was a talk the teacher was just
like trying to talk about like long
division we're like [__] all this have
you seen the C Cups yeah [__] all this
even the teacher was like God damn yeah
have you seen a square root of them
[__] those [__] long nuggets D
Squared yeah how much can how big can
tits be on a and I don't want to say on
a child because we've said this kind of
stuff before and but this is what we're
looking up do you understand what I'm
saying
all right
see this is the problem go Incognito
yeah see that's what you have to do is
is before you type you say for a podcast
and then colon and then do it
yeah or just because I'm not I'm not
curious and I'll never look anywhere
you're gonna open the browser just Chris
Hanson with two Glocks
you interviewed him yeah yeah okay the
guy say yeah the guy stopped hundreds of
pedophiles man yeah there was an episode
where his friend walked in uh-uh yeah
he's like oh [__] is that so-and-so
that's got to be tough
yeah
what happened Zach
yeah I I'm I don't have details on this
question yet
what do you get if you put that in uh
Texas Children's Hospital breast
development questions okay
well this is kind of like what you said
if you go back on one page oh here's a
good question why are my breasts big
first of all it should be plural at a
young age but that's kind of what you
had but with a with a wiener that's true
so that's a good point actually so
imagine going to bed one night and you
can't lay all the way down because you
suddenly have tits that's gotta be yeah
yeah crazy for a girl you can't get
massage you can't do anything up
he's always planking oh yeah that's
crazy dude well life is a plank yeah I
don't know dude I was a late bloomer I
wanted uh were you really yeah I
remember in PE everybody had like
deodorant and like armpit hair dude so I
had this like giant stuffed animal in my
room probably made love to it definitely
made love to it and I used to cut the
hair off it and put it in my armpit
because I wanted armpit hair that bad
just see what it looked like oh yeah
yeah and the color was it it was black
so it didn't match any of my Ginger
tones at all but I'd put water on my
armpit then I put it in there and I'd
look in the mirror and be like dude this
is this could be me one day yeah and I
still do that to this day I love that
it's amazing yeah I don't you weren't a
late bloomer if you had implants arm
hair uh armpit if you had armpit hair
implants oh dude I was just putting
Rogaine on every morning is that Old
Spice Knoxville game dude I distinctly
remember like you said when you went to
PE and somebody had deodorant for the
first time that was a kid it blew your
mind you're like oh now we have to get
deodorant yeah this is where I learn
like okay yeah I use deodorant like what
do you use you know when you start you
would name like uh
um like duh like uh yeah exactly dish
soap recipe
exactly yeah yeah I remember just I
wanted to yeah like Reebok what do you
guys use Reebok yeah yeah what do you
roll on is that Alex yeah no he's a
machete I every day I saw somebody doing
that like I remember the first day I had
armpit sweat I was excited I was like
this is puberty yeah it's knocking you
know I remember when I had like a little
like blonde mustache yeah
how's I'm not shaving this [__] I'd
rather look like I sell used taquitos
yeah dude oh especially on a guy like I
think red-headed guys or guys that that
lean Auburn or gin yeah or gangers they
call them
um they uh or you guys are almost
adopted into the black community I feel
like you guys are we do get [__] on a
lot no no a lot of like wiggas as they
say which is a popular term from the
past 100 or 150 years it it you guys are
often they're often gingers or gangers
yeah I I do feel that I do yeah my first
job I was the only white guy there when
I first moved to LA it was like 80 black
dudes and me and it was one of the best
jobs in my life they respect you guys a
lot more I think let's pull up wiggas
and see what they've been doing if you
don't mind let's see uh like where they
uh follow their S Corp what have they
been doing when selling whippets and
just put click on images and let's see
who we get yeah that's what is
is that Hollywood wiggers what is that
wait a sec
yeah that sounds like that's Adam DeVine
isn't it that does look like him
San Diego does have a high breed of this
now there you go
where do you think spawns this person
what city comes to mind when you think
of this I think of Little Rock oh yes
Little Rock something about that
yeah my friend Justin is from Arkansas
and uh he likes to gun down them
gobblers over there but he said that
there is a lot of
um wig-esque so what are these behaviors
that are also on here this has nothing
to do with the white guy with the orange
Camaro let's go to this guy a popular
diagram called the wiggers diagram what
is that it's a standard diagram used in
cardiac physiologically named after Dr
Carl J wiggers dude
Carl Carl J Dude you got to go by just
Carl J at that point so people are going
to learn about this in school
I mean dude our chart looked way
different it was a ginger dude and it
cross sectioned with a UNC uh basketball
tournament and he had a yo-yo and a vape
for some reason that'd be so funny if
you open up that page and he drove a
Honda Civic which was the number one car
but he like chipped off the word civic
and put like BMW logos on there there's
nothing better than that when somebody
takes like the Chrysler 300 puts like a
Bentley logo on it yeah those are people
who come off insane but I respect it oh
I respect that too it's just like you're
because that's all the car is sometimes
it's just an extra emblem you know yeah
100 what was your first car
my first car was a 1984 Ford Escort and
I paid cash for it somebody stole the
passenger seat
didn't want you in that carpool lane or
what I don't know what the issue was I
just remember picking people up and they
had to get in and
there was like a bus you were in the bus
you were the bus driver up front and the
people had to walk past you they pay you
a fare like oh aboard just one seat in
the back
just one lady yo let's get back there
um but so I want to talk more about that
uh yeah whenever you hit puberty man
that [__] was wild I remember
it feels like you ever put a a a Mentos
and a Diet Pepsi or Diet Coke
yeah and it starts to Bubble Up at first
that's what it feels like your body's
doing it's starting to Bubble Up at
first
I think I remembered I'm trying to think
everyone remember getting body hair
maybe a little on my chest like in the
crack of my chest yeah yeah I got a few
of those um oh right here you get that
happy trail and that's CR you want to
keep it you wanna you can't wait to go
to the pool and take your shirt off yeah
dude some people even put a little
Barrett a lot of the brothers will put a
little Barrette on it
little bow tie down there yeah small
nothing crazy yeah exactly you know just
something chill something to flex a
little I grew up in kind of like a white
and urban area so you'd have dude I
remember they had a handicap dude a
black dude and he was uh
he was uh his legs weren't getting work
and they had braided his [__] legs
around each other yeah you should yeah
yeah you know that's what I would do or
I put underglow on him
like on the bottom so they shine a
little personally yeah because then it
looks like the Lord's carrying me you
know you're right I've never seen a
wheelchair with underglow but if your
legs had it wouldn't you be like oh he's
not walking because he can float I don't
know man I just I saw a car with
underglow recently driving uh from the
IE the Inland Empire and it brought me
back like this Spinners era
I think they should have pent my
wheelchair and um that's just me trying
to help out them spree whales yeah well
you'll see sometimes there's uh a lot of
dudes are in wheelchairs they'll do that
dolphin where they kind of pull up in
this let the wheels yeah yeah you know
those know what they're doing but again
yeah but if I spent my life in a
wheelchair I'd get bored after a while I
definitely want to you think I think so
I definitely want to learn the tricks
sometimes I'll pretend like this like
I'll like even if I'm like at a uh
dinner or something or like I'm building
at a table for a while and people don't
you know I'll kind of do this you know
but looks like you're about to start a
bobsled yeah just for fun yeah just to
let people know that you still you could
be if you needed to but yeah I think I'm
trying to remember to what that was like
it's crazy that like everybody happens
to your body and you don't even you're
not like documenting every day it's like
it's because it's unreal yeah it feels
like you're just waiting in line and
eventually it's like the Lord being like
you better get some pubes and but it's a
slow process it's not like you walk up
to the front door and they stamp your
puberty card it's like a slow a little
bit of this a little bit of that the
voice cracks if when your voice cracked
in class I mean that was one of the
worst days of my life especially late oh
yeah when I was at 17 you get her ass
beat at noon for sure
yeah it's crazy yeah that man would
start to [__] break out of you it's
almost like the Incredible Hulk when he
breaks through his own clothing it's
like when snakes uh shed a little bit
but it's just the manliness is coming
out yeah you'd be like can we go get
some I'm trying to [__] you know just
like like whoa whoa what happened and
then you try to do that voice again but
you can't do it you're trying to get
back to here yeah you couldn't do it
you're trying to get back you could
never do it you remember coming to
school and one kid had like just gone
way past puberty like he was like seven
dude he had like arthritis I'm like you
missed like 19 stages
he had a beard yeah he had a beard and
that kid always had to buy beer then
dude there's a guy his name was Chuck
and he had a full facial hair in ninth
grade and he was dating an eighth grader
and he this is a hilarious story and if
you're from my hometown you know the
story
he was dating this chick and they did
anal and she had to miss school the next
day no way yeah this is ninth grade bro
I barely even seen one of my [__] like
I I was so nerd like so you almost been
freaking out right this guy was like Dan
Bilzerian of ninth grade I was looking
at him like tell me your secrets oh and
he used to not wear uh boxers he'd wear
just denim just denim on dick no boxers
raw dog in it raw dog in that denim dude
it was crazy but the girl literally had
to miss school the next day because she
couldn't walk no and he and he works at
a restaurant now but yeah he does yeah
he's serving it up but wow that like
that guy was so many levels ahead of
puberty than I was it was crazy oh when
you heard about the first guy that had
sex kind of like like I remember we came
back from seventh grade and some kid had
had sex apparently like on a pool chair
or something yeah it was always outside
and people were losing their mind people
didn't know what to do people were like
trying to like install a pool at the
school like people had never seen my
beach ball like everything just banana
because they just
it's like you want to get as close to
you can as you can to say yes you know
it was like the first person that went
to the moon everybody was just like tell
me how you did it what was it like in
there like could you really like Bounce
Around did you feel like yourself well I
met the guy that did it man the the
green screen Buzz Aldrin yo yeah yeah
you met him yeah wow what did he say it
was like
um
do you think it was real oh well I'll
tell you this man if I went out I
remember this when I looked at him
it didn't seem like he'd been to the
Moon
we'll give it away
just something just she was describing
it like a like a 12 year old talking
about tits yeah it was a pretty cool
it's bouncy yeah you know there was they
were bigger than I thought yeah but I
could handle it
you didn't see it in his eyes
yeah they're just something he just uh I
don't know you know what I'm saying you
if I met if I met somebody who'd been to
the who've been to to go uh the Galaxy
or whatever I would know right well it's
like somebody like if I told you I've
been in jail you would look at my body
and be like you have not right you have
picked up a friend from juvie but that
is the most but there's something about
like an energy so I see what you're
saying yeah maybe you zoomed with like a
um
like a PO or something yeah exactly
sugar man's hand who's the data guy so
that was a thing for me and I'm not
discrediting the space program or NASA
but that's just what I thought my
grandpa used to work for NASA yeah he
was a veteran and work for NASA really
he was like the mainland guy like he he
always wore the same outfit every day he
was jacked like 65 worked for NASA and a
fought in war
oh that's crazy I'm a [__] tick
tocker like what like this guy has lived
a legacy yeah he's one time I saw him
eat an orange with the peel on whole
thing like an apple and the thing he
said after was like the most badass
thing he was like when you're in the the
war you have an option you can either
like peel your orange and you know Take
Your Eye Off what's going on or you can
risk in your face peeled by a caliber
I'd never heard something so cool in my
life wow yeah it was really cool he's a
great man was he yeah and like if I like
ever disrespected my mom he like my mom
had like a bodyguard if I ever
disrespected my mom or said something
like I don't want to eat the [__]
frozen peas he tastes like [__] he'd be
like he'd always put something down
right and then be like don't you treat
my daughter that way and I could just he
wouldn't hit me but mentally he did yeah
he's a manless man I knew [__] that's
amazing man what was his name burnt Bert
that's a good name yeah no he was he was
awesome wow man that's really neat dude
and uh how did he pass away Sage oh Bert
yeah yeah yeah super cool man and he
fought in the War so he would uh he
would always say crazy [__] in the car
and I was too young and noticed at the
time but my mom would always be like you
can't you can't say that anymore you
could that's you shouldn't be saying
that anymore I should be sitting in the
back it was like a live Jerry Springer
was awesome yeah well yeah like I
remember watching football yeah with my
grandfather and he'd been in one of the
wars and the guy would like they'd be
like the guy ran a slant or whatever and
he'd be like if a slant runs by here
they'll [__] know what's going on
like he would say crazy [__] I'm like
whoa dude that's not you know you just
anybody that kind of fought in the War
I try to make a joke about that on stage
sometimes like anybody that fought the
War like you're just like kind of okay
with them being like slightly
a little uh Prejudice or something you
might be like you're just like ah
they're in the war they fought for the
country you know but if they didn't like
if they didn't fought a war and they
said the same [__] you'd be like yo
[__] pull that man's Life Alert
that's [__] up but if you notice how
to use a bayonet yeah
you're right literally you know this is
between him and the Lord right now
don't intercept what he's trying to
think I don't know you know if you're
selling things you have to get them to
the customer
that's right if you sell something
you sell a shift a robe you sell a a
little omelette maker a cute one that
makes the omelets and the shapes
Christmas ornament shapes or whatever
little pumpkins whatever
you got to ship your product
ship station can help that's right
if you're an e-commerce business owner
shipping is no longer a manual task
thanks to ship station
effortless integration anywhere you sell
online including Amazon eBay Shopify
Etsy and more and with Enterprise
solutions that make Warehouse
optimization easy ship station scales
when you do
get up to 84 percent off
USPS and UPS rates and if that's not
enough use my promo code to try ship
station free
for two months
go to shipstation.com and use code
t-h-e-o today and sign up for your free
60-day trial that's
shipstation.com code Theo keep your hair
do you have hair who has hair huh raise
your hand if you don't that's okay
there's help
if you're losing your hair
more than 50 million men in the U.S
suffer from mpb baby male pattern
baldness that's what they call it
well keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors
it's expert recommended hair loss
treatments they will personalize a
treatment plan
for you a licensed medical provider you
can easily subscribe to keeps you get
refill reminders it's low cost
you want to keep that hair you want to
stay wigging around homie you want to be
wigged out
they'll do it
that's right keeps helpless men keep
their hair and prevent hair loss that's
what it does
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o to get your
first month free keeps.com slash Theo
dude it is kind of crazy how like
like people that like serve the country
and help protect the country and like
establish the borders and like
um they kind of
throw them by the wayside as they get
older because like they're
like or here's what I'm saying is it's
interesting how like like our parents
might have like different views than
like probably a lot of younger
generation has right
um probably a lot of more old-fashioned
views but their parents like went off to
war to like protect like the the free
the safety of the nation and stuff like
that yeah so when they're like pissed
off about the Border it's like you kind
of have to respect where they're coming
from if they had a parent that died
somewhere defending the board you know
what I'm saying are like establishing
the land of America it's like that a lot
of times that stuff gets so like not
even factored into the way that people
behave like yeah I could understand if
one like my mom
feel certain ways about like um
protecting like the freedoms of America
and like defending our border and like
looking out for America first if she had
a grandfather or a father that was gone
for a [__] right eight months or a
year out of her life because he was out
defending it or whatever the problem is
when there's the disconnect when uh
after Generations it fades away you know
if your dad was that guy then it's very
strong to you and now when you have the
child it's like it gets less and less
and now it's like I hear about the war
and I'm like yeah but like what about
the tick tock algorithm like that's the
war I'm fighting yeah what about war
yeah Minecraft yeah exactly yeah
somebody who's like a better gamer now
is like better than like
um who was that General during like Iraq
or something that was uh Colin Powell or
Petraeus yeah
Petraeus now is it like is like the same
as like some who's like one of the best
Gamers right now
uh I know ninja was big or like all the
FaZe Clan dudes like Shinobi or somebody
you know or whoever
you know yeah it's that disconnect where
it's like it's well I mean it's like now
it's like I I've done a lot of like
college shows and
80 of the audience wasn't alive for 9
11. and it's like you say 9 11 to them
and it's just like a date to them and it
like blows my mind but it's like yeah
that was me learning about World War II
I don't I don't know I was in a nut sack
somewhere balled up yeah waiting for my
draft yeah
yeah so it's just a time thing I think
but it is bizarre
what's crazy too how we just don't even
like refle yeah it is wild how much
things change and then how like we kind
of don't take into account what other
people like what their generation was
like you know correct it's almost like
you're they're suddenly like wrong just
because they're getting older because
um like times have kind of changed you
know
yeah
um but anyway what else can we talk
about that's a little more [__]
normal dude what else is going on in the
news Zach a lot of stuff huh
yeah we got a couple stories here I
guess a former bodyguard's launching a
ride sharing app where the drivers will
be armed with guns oh I heard about this
in Atlanta right
yeah yeah
I would use that but I would go to
places where you wouldn't need bodyguard
just to just feel cool it's called black
wolf black wolf wow an app designed a
riable uber and Lyft recently launched
in Atlanta and is about to drop in New
York
uh Carrie King Brown revealed he created
the app as a necessary evil who are
mostly on the news getting robbed
getting raped the average person
well yeah who else is it going to be
Senators yeah you could take down a
senator pretty easy though but who else
is going to be animals or something like
who is it like yeah that's that is
interesting like where would you take
this like what's something you'd be
going to like if I was doing like a kid
rock yep
I mean easily Memphis dude uh shout out
Memphis a Raiders game Raiders game yeah
yeah I think that
um
I think maybe like a kid rock cover band
concert oh yeah you know yeah I could
possibly see it needed for that too so
what happens they just send you with the
driver with a gun because I think most
Uber drivers if you go to like
Sacramento probably just have a gun on
them yeah it seems like the drivers are
specially trained like they mentioned
one of the drivers a private
investigator and previously worked as a
bodyguard so it's not that just they
have the gun it's like they're
professionally trained protectors okay
got it so what I'm creating is a
necessary evil it's a necessity it says
um Brown is no ordinary driver and he's
no regular man with a plan he is a
private investigator and has worked as a
bodyguard for celebrities and
politicians he wants to share his own
brand of executive protection with the
world so this is one of those things I
think you're starting to see like you
know like this there's too many
insanely rich people out there I think
yeah you know walking around right I
think there should be a cap on how much
money that you can make
then what
you lose it and get back up like if you
overshoot in 21 oh yeah
no but here's what happens I think they
then like says like the town or wherever
you're from let's you get something like
named after you like there's some like
there's some value that's given to you
because of the way you're creating stuff
or you have to give more to your
employee like I don't know something
like but I think part of it is like
you're just starting to see like a lot
of rich people are probably getting
scared of people that are like shooting
at him what do you think
I mean yeah that's a huge problem here
in La like rich people getting robbed
all the time oh yeah like a Rolex on
Rodeo so it runs up and grabs it yeah
that's the people gonna get this it's
not gonna be he says it's for regular
people but what regular person's gonna
get that yeah unless they're going to
prom or something they don't want
somebody else that's funny hitting on
their chick or something yeah I don't I
don't know when
I don't even know when I would like use
that
or like when I would feel like oh [__]
you know maybe Black Friday show up to
Walmart people be shooting over flat
screens oh shooting over an air fryer
yeah so maybe I'll pull up with that
there
yeah I think it's well it's going to
become first of all it's going to become
a niche thing that rich people are gonna
do yeah so rich people who have a ton of
extra Expendable income they just want
to spend it any way they can to look
even richer if you could hire somebody
to be with you at all times who would it
be would it be like a bodyguard an
escort uh maybe like uh someone who
knows a lot about like zoo animals what
do you think it would be
oh that's a good question I think I
would think like a middle like somebody
like a really buff mom I think
oh I'd hire like a total wigger to hang
out with me all day
like my boy Brian Purvis that I grew up
with dog who's Brian Purvis R.I.P man oh
what happened no he's not dead but he is
in uh he's in jail for so long that it's
like he might as well be no but he's
interesting nobody in the outside is
going to get to know him you know and
he's wild if you're in jail for life
right there maybe that's him yeah oh wow
he got the see if that guy told me he's
been to the Moon yeah I wouldn't believe
him but I would buy Molly off him yeah
he's got the I got that good Molly on
him he got those moon rocks yeah oh so
what happened
um attempted murder I could just I would
like to hang out with him bro or just
like some real like just some dude
that's real like as real as it can get
like he's always rubbing his hands yeah
somebody that's a real as he can get bro
some dude that uh he can just he has to
move his head side to side like this to
even move forward or to come up with a
good idea yeah you ask him what smoothie
he wants and he's like yeah he's
thinking about catalytic converters and
[__] yeah he doesn't blink unless he's
you know he sees you blink he's [__]
right you know remind himself to Blink
on his hand it says blank and he goes
yeah his whoop bracelet yeah yeah he
always knows a good like ICP playlist oh
dude his uh his aunt his um house arrest
bracelet oh yeah it's got the Wu-Tang
logo on it it makes a special beep when
he walks to a grocery store entrance
yeah that's how he does Apple pay with
an ankle monitor yeah that's crazy dude
he just puts his [__] uh his British
night up on the uh you ever been
arrested
we was at a house somewhere and the cops
came in
and they went upstairs right this is the
crazy thing and they bring a kid down
from upstairs everybody's High
downstairs if you had no idea who the
kid was no and everybody's like who the
[__] here as a kid nobody had a kid
right
it was we were kids right they bring
like a sleeping kid with like a um I
think they tried to plan it on you you
know how it totally seem like like when
somebody gets like shot and they
sprinkled Coke on them oh it's a
cokehead yeah these kids were funneling
kids but like yeah with the kid it was
like he was like rubbing his eye and he
had on like a little night guy I mean
yeah it seemed like something like a
Charles Dickens novel yeah I was gonna
say kids are always rubbing their eyes
in movies yeah so it seemed really like
a setup in Mississippi and so we had to
go stay in for the night I'm trying to
think if there was another time
I feel like I did another time
I got put in the back of a cop car for
keeping a house in eighth grade
suburb [__] wow yeah what a gang was
that ah dude [__] Charmin Ultra
[__] hard Charmin yeah single ply
[__]
you went through some [__] yeah a little
nah [__] went through you yeah oh yeah
fingers went through some [__] yeah but
I was remember me and my friend Matt had
a backpack on and if you see any kid
with a backpack four in the morning yeah
he ain't going to school
so the cops just pulled over and I had
like four rolls on me just Charming yeah
my parents are probably more so pissed
that I was throwing the nice toilet
paper yeah but yeah the cops were like
what are you doing then I had to go wake
my parents up and then my parents had to
go talk to the cop and my neighbor at
the time was the sheriff that's the only
reason we like got anything they're like
oh [__] I know your neighbor that's
that's the [__] you know yeah and so
they just I don't know how that helped
but uh yeah it was it that's all I did
was wicking my parents like it was a cop
downstairs like the [__] that was it
damn that was such a weird time as a kid
when you had to go get your parents up
at night remember that oh because like
can we go you'd have to open their door
going by there and you knew they were
asleep right and it was that moment
where you're like how do I time where I
knock maybe they're like not like maybe
I'll give them an extra five seconds to
sleep or something yeah how do you like
and then you're like Mom yeah yeah you
having another nightmare uh no
um there's a squad car out front cops
are here yeah and your dad was in some
weird PJs and yeah dick was probably
flopping out man [__] are you talking
about yeah it was weird I don't think I
got in trouble for that I think it was
just I don't even I don't even remember
what happened
yeah that that all that time was just
interesting man what were we talking
about on the news that happened today
Atlanta
oh yeah Atlanta so yeah I'm just
wondering yeah I think you're just gonna
start seeing more rich people get
um like special services yeah just to
spend their money because they have to I
wonder if it's just going to get so
mainstream like imagine where like these
dudes aren't doing it in combat like
these dudes are trained tactically to
like [__] somebody up but now you're
just dropping somebody off at LAX like I
get bored I'm like I know how to shoot a
gun why are you making me drive to you
know American Airlines well then at a
certain point those guys are going to
want to shoot guns yeah I think they
should they're going to want to pop off
on somebody they're gonna want to um
yeah can you get the trunk for me
They're Gonna Wanna put a piece into
somebody they're going to want to put a
free filling in somebody's [__] rib
cage yeah because I think they're just
gonna be like loading in that car like I
wanna [__] hit someone yeah or they
might start some beef well shit's
getting weird now I notice when I uh
walk up to a car now it used to be you
could walk up to happen tap on the
window or ask somebody a question seems
crazy to do now doesn't it yeah bro the
other day I'm walking up to a car and I
was like
oh my God
well you also look like somebody who's
gonna sell you some like fake fish
tickets oh yeah
you know what I'm saying bro alpha or
some fake Matt or some fake fish
that's like
y'all [__] with these it's just a
hamster with a fin on the back so wait
what are we saying I cut you off it's
either modest Yahoo or mahi mahi dude
yeah yeah yeah you're buying something
yeah so you walked into a car and what
happened I don't mean but it spooked me
out I was like oh my God if this person
would have just drawn on me yeah and
shot me there would have been a case for
them that this guy came up on my car
whether or not I had a weapon or not
yeah there would it wouldn't have been
just like an open shut thing of like you
shooting a stranger right you approach
my bubble remember that and people say
get out of my bubble that was some mom
[__] but so what do you do if you're
like out of red light and somebody like
walks up to your car you you break you
keep your eyes on the road or you talk
with them or you just look forward or
like it is weird like you you just stand
there and you're like pretend you're at
the wheel and you're just like
pretending that they're not there or do
you interact I mean if they come up to
the window of your car like who are they
why would someone do that there's
somebody looking for money okay well
that's almost different because you
almost are kind of expecting and in that
moment I feel like at a stoplight you're
kind of looking around I think for me
like there were cars in a parking lot
they were parked and what happened was I
thought I walked up to we had a rental
car I thought I would walk up to the
rental car I walked up to the wrong car
but I walked up and kind of like
was by I mean I'm like right by the
glass there's somebody sitting in that
car and I'm like if that person years
ago would have been like oh I'm so sorry
it's an accident but now it's like their
windows are all tinted everything so
it's like I don't know it just felt like
if they shot me it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be crazy yeah you like last
words would be I get it I it does feel
like the brain just trains you to
anytime like somebody comes up to your
car you should be oh like like fight or
flight immediately but everybody's
scared now I feel like and we're
building up this um
but sometimes you go like a real small
town and they're like the opposite like
you walk up they're like you need some
honey I remember I was doing a show
that's a good point I was in Butte
Montana and there's a population of like
456 maybe 450
for today but that I was walking from
the Walmart to my hotel yeah and this
lady Drives By and she goes do you need
help and I was like and like this is
like very early in my career so I
thought I was like hot [__] and I was
like oh maybe she recognized me I was
like no what's up she's like oh anytime
you see somebody walking in this town
that means something you know something
bad happened I was just helping you out
and that was that yeah no offers of sex
or nothing yeah
yeah I think that that's a good point so
I'm thinking for more like a city
perspective where was this at this was
in uh Phoenix okay yeah there's a lot of
walking up to cars out there but I just
had never thought that before I never
thought that before like if somebody if
I walk up somebody's car that they would
if they did shoot me or the I just had
never thought that there was that much
fear in the air or like uh yeah weird
energy and like uncertainty I think
people are just very nervous about what
other people are capable of yeah that is
true I think everyone's just like on the
heightened senses yeah I think some of
it's because you see a lot of clips of
people like beating people up on like
Twitter and stuff do you ever see any of
that stuff no of course Twitter's just
tits and people getting knocked out yeah
which is pretty good combo yeah it's
like the new Spike TV where the [__] is
Spike TV I miss that [__] mancers every
time it would be like my girlfriend is
talking too much a big [__] divorced
that [__] and the Spike TV we'll be
back to you after this Jack Links Beef
Jerky commercial yeah I miss Spike TV
that was just like creatine for the soul
dude Spike TV was so [__] good it was
like um they had like cat like um I
don't even know they were like uh oh
watch this guy get his uh get a root
canal done with a forklift yeah and he
does it himself yeah but they had to
show A Thousand Ways To Die
you ever see that they would just find
random cases around the world then they
would hire reenactment actors to be like
yeah I'd be like this guy was climbing
the Christmas tree to try to put the
final thing in the ornament and got you
know electrocuted in the [__] yeah it
was a really weird show they would just
reenact how random deaths would happen
I wonder if there's like one actor that
does a lot of the death reenactments you
know oh there he was the go-to guy on
call yeah now he's just at a bar like
you were seeing a thousand ways to die
that was me yeah that was me 40 of them
were me yeah
yeah what other shows does Spike TV have
I just remember the name and the feeling
associated with they had early UFC I
think was on Spike TV wasn't it was it
UFC or just a bunch of dudes fighting in
front of a Red Lobster uh I think it
could have been either one that's Maine
that you're talking about yeah there's
nothing better than like a raw street
fight you ever just been driving by I
see a fight it may have been a ring cam
from Maine yeah exactly yeah dude bro I
was in New York the other day right so
there's like two home there's like a
homeless dude and what we thought was
like a regular dude like we're sitting
outside of a cafe and I don't go to
cafes dude because they're gay right my
buddy wanted to go yeah I was gonna say
I can't see you sitting there sipping a
little cappuccino with a pinky out yeah
I was just dude I was buying Coke and
then selling it to other people I don't
do it anymore but exactly grams you
notice that [__] keep me hype right
right just to stay cool at the cafe yeah
what can I give you an eight ball you
wanted iced
so to we saw some dudes of me and my
buddy Kevin were like all right well
let's go see what's going on here so we
get up from our little table and the
tables in New York so small especially
cafes how [__] small is this table
yeah it's insane I do like the arguments
when you're like sitting at a table at a
restaurant in New York you can hear the
people like directly to your left and
right couples aren't doing well in New
York no because I get a lot of hot
people I wouldn't want to be on a
relationship at that time either oh dude
everything that walked by I wanted to
put my face in it you know it's an
insane I couldn't imagine
feeling like I was in a comfortable
relationship in that town like you're
both walking be like wow that girl's so
hot and she's like wow that dude's so
hot and you're just like huh okay I
can't wait to go back to Easter with
your family next weekend yeah [__]
everybody oh dude it's just like you
just want to [__] you know it's crazy
in the fashion out there you just want a
damn Pink Eye collection you know like
you're [__] willing to get in the
organic way too
yeah not a fart on the pillow just fart
on these goddamn eyelids oh damn yeah I
put these things to sleep honey yes but
it's no hot town so we heard two
homeless dude wait we thought it was a
homeless dude and a regular dude
fighting so it's over not fair for the
regular dude he'll get his ass beat well
we didn't know what was happening so we
cruise over and then one of them they're
beating each other with uh toilet tissue
with a bunch of packet packet of [__]
tickets right so one of them's banging
the other dude up with this with like a
eight pack of [__] tickets dude and
we're like oh dude hey what's going on
here guys yeah and it was a black guy
and a white guy and like what's going on
here guys who is what uh I can't
remember who and then at that point we
realized oh both of these guys are home
are like kind of crackheads or whatever
yeah yeah you know like or they were
drug induced were they having fun though
that kind of sounds fun no it sounds
like a street pillow fight it did a
little but then they Apollo they're like
we're so sorry they kept cursing at each
other and kept hitting each other with
uh with toilet tissue and
but it was weird because we went from
thinking like all right let's step in
here and see if we can help out or
what's going to go on to it oh yeah oh
[__] both these guys are [__] like
mentally unwell like do you see the
fight at Disneyland last week yeah a
couple whites huh yeah I love a good uh
public fight it's so funny well I always
thought that this was a black thing
until white people so this is basically
cultural appropriation now white people
fighting well fighting at Disney world
because
they'd had one group of black people
that had done it pretty well a while
back remember that Zach yeah
and they do that like places like matter
like Space Mountain like fun places to
watch a fight yeah they have a jail at
Disneyland oh they do yeah oh I haven't
been but that'd be nice dropping the
soap there
yeah
let's get a quick little yeah oh boy
somebody's giving goofy in that ass
I don't know dude I'm trying to think if
you had to make love to one cartoon who
would it be bro uh the girl from
Futurama Lola she had three tits and one
eye that's a great combo right there
let's bring her up I think I think it
was three kids in one I wasn't really
looking past the oh she only had two
tits yeah there's only two no she had
three bro you're thinking of Total
Recall yeah
I'm thinking of a good night she just
kind of does something it's like the
purple hair like she she would be a
bartender at a place in Hollywood and
wouldn't look at you and that's hard to
do with that eye but she would like she
wouldn't look you know well having oh
yeah I see what you're saying but also
I'm going to say this having one eye
there would be something so nice if
somebody when I you ever really try to
look at somebody in the eyes just one
I'm doing it right now like but in both
uh it's almost impossible because you
can't you don't know where to yeah
you're there's always a little bit of
somebody told me a trick for like
interviews you stare in the middle of
the nose like the like right in between
the eyes because it looks you can't
really tell
but also I think one eye is kind of
seductive because like imagine you do
like one of these sort of cheek and she
like blushes and like the one eye goes
down that's pretty hot but that one eye
is bigger and imagine if she starts
crying and one big tear comes out wow
and I could break an iPhone yeah you
gotta get a bowl of rice and everything
who's your cartoon you'd go for let me
think the cartoon that's oh Jessica
Rabbit huh Jessica Rabbit does it yeah
God yeah boy I just wanted to draw my
own dick on her
I remember when I saw that oh what about
uh Lola I thought she was a real woman I
was like Mom we have to go meet her oh
do you know how many uh wishes she's on
for Christmas beat you in the yard if
you don't calm down is that what
happened if you got too horned up your
mom would just beat you in the yard oh
dude my mom if we were lucky she'd get a
can she'd get uh some canned beer and go
sit in the yard for a while God
sometimes I wish somebody would beat my
ass when I get too horny it's Sunday
like if I just start like swiping on
dating apps I wish somebody would just
punch me in the back of your head and be
like go write a new joke oh you're right
yeah it would be good you think about
that horniness slows down takes up so
much of your time look at that how much
horniness does uh my therapist literally
told me the other day that I should try
jerking off to get these thoughts out of
my head
and I was like where the [__] did you
get your degree at Arizona State
University because I was like I was like
I feel like sometimes I like I'm going
on dates I don't know if I just like the
attention or do I do I like I don't want
to waste anybody's time but like do I
like these people or is it just the
attention and he's like well before you
like start texting people back like just
jerk off and it was like such a simple
it's the only time he's ever given me an
answer usually has questions he'll be
like well how does it make you feel why
does it make you feel but this is the
only time he's like just touch yourself
and I was like damn bro
and I did and it works for about 38
minutes wow really creeps back in you
got that Half-Life so you so you're you
come right back around pretty quick when
you make love to a woman yeah all right
are you willing or able to make love
again the same night the same night yeah
but it's got to be like a full like
Family Guy episode like it's not like it
might I don't know it could like here's
all I go I can get back up but the nut
ain't
replenished you know yeah so I'm like in
a car driving downhill but there's no
engine in there oh but I'm driving but
nobody so it's almost like the engine's
off but you're still going down you're
coasting yeah but there's no there's no
rev power yeah and then I gotta lie I'm
like oh I finished and then
didn't
so I'd be faking it too ladies
oh I remember the first time I ever got
did six this lady how old were you by
the way
well two things happen one I uh
one I tried to have sex with a girl and
I just got close to her and just
e-jacked all over
and I just churned out baby I mean he's
built up oh God boy that's probably for
the best I mean you could hear a [__]
wolf howl that [__] was pure brother
that's uncut nut oh that [__] yeah just
straight from the the Pacific so how
close was she to you
um
she was probably four inches away from
me in bed I could just feel my body
getting closer to hers and just closer
and then I just
and I was like are you is everything
okay are you okay and I was like I
didn't know what had happened kind of
how'd you get out of it uh I said we
should get out of here right and then
say cops are on the way I don't know
what I said dude but I got so scared and
nervous that uh I made her climb out of
the windows anything to take your mind
off the fact that you pre-came yeah I
was like you got to get the [__] out of
here why the dogs are out front the dogs
are barking yes I was like you have to
get the [__] out of here and there was
nobody else even at our house so it was
like yeah
the window yeah that's crazy now in and
then yeah so that was the first almost
and then I ended up making love to this
girl behind the bowling alley in our
town over there bowling all is kind of a
seductive place a lot of like this
action right here these three fingers
get a lot of work then all of a sudden
you know
there's actually if you pull it up on uh
it's still out there there's um Tiffany
Lanes it was called I would love if the
first review or like it was like Tiffany
Lane where Theo Von got his [__] touched
yeah is it in there oh my God honestly
somebody did it I'm here because it's
the Yvonne who lost some of the
Impressions at the bowling alley so long
oh dude this is real yep Tiffany Lane's
bowling alley over there they gave it
five stars too temporarily closed
you should reopen it we shut it oh
really that wouldn't be a bad idea to
reopen you should what would you call it
Theo's nut Hut Tiffany's Lane
timings Tiffany slant yeah I think you
should you remember when the punchline
in San Francisco was gonna close down
and then Chappelle was like here's a
bunch of money to keep it open you
should do that with this place Tiffany
Lane
um
what was the review on there Zach I
don't know if we read it it was a they
said I'm only here because the Yovan
lost something precious that's so funny
that that's
you've I I've been meaning to tell you
this you have the best fans honestly
really they're great with all the shows
that I've done with you they're so
they're just excited they're just happy
to be there oh thanks man the energy
just is but it feels both because
I don't know I love doing any of your
shows and anytime and last time I did uh
this past weekend a bunch of positive
comments and yeah yeah it's just a great
fan base they just all they're there for
not only you but each other I think and
I think a lot of the clips I see on Tick
Tock are a bunch of really funny stuff
but also people will clip like the
moments where you're just real there was
one recently we were talking about
you're like I don't know if I'm doing my
to-do list or I don't know whose to-do
list I'm doing and all the comments were
like dude I [__] sympathize with I I
feel this this is like the real Theo so
people respect you on both sides you
know because if I open up and be myself
like not that I'm not but like if I
really open up and I'm like this is what
makes me sad at live people but man shut
the [__] up don't make a video about
Celsius you idiot so for you it's like I
think people are around like 360. they
love Theo 360. oh interesting man and
and look I I know people do care about
me and and all that and I'm just
fabricating all that stuff but I think
like you know if I if I post anything
that's not like a sketch or stand up
you're like what the [__] is this yeah
go back to making videos of porn stars
idiot you know but I think people just
love you so much for anything and
everything you do thanks man it's it's
really cool there's a lot of special
fans yeah a lot of special people out
there I noticed it too a lot of nice
people come out will leave nice things
leave nice messages I have a lot of good
interaction with people on socials and
stuff just or a lot of people struggling
with different things I think also
probably since I'm older than you like
you'll have probably more times like
that in the future where you'll get to
spaces in your life like yeah you know
you're still making sure that people and
just like I am like you just you know
you want to make sure that people accept
you or whatever you know and but um it
does feel like that a lot but yeah I
think uh yeah I feel like that when I
did an elk I just did an elk podcast how
was that it was good man I like being
around dude I'm kind of fascinated by by
their business it's hilarious and what
they do and they keep like like kind of
axing people from their [__] pot like
people kind of disappear it's bizarre
it's like everybody in there is like is
a boyfriend a girlfriend and then
they're like we're [__] done with
that [__] and then next week they're
like we're back together but now he's
done with that like it's just an
ever-changing door but Kyle's the one
that like Remains the Same and then
everyone else kind of rotates around him
but dude I mean like no podcast is
um and I would gladly do it hit me up
but I remember I took like two days off
social media and the first thing I
opened was my phone it was Donald Trump
being asked about I spice by Kyle and
I'm like what how do we get here and
Donald Trump's like I spice what a woman
great hair love the bush
it is you know I think everything's kind
of merged that's how it felt it was like
a U.S president is doing a podcast alone
is a wild topic but to be doing the nail
boys podcast where they're doing like
it's like all right up next Donald Trump
but first Blue Shield does your dick not
work it's just it's what you said it's
worlds combining and then we're all
turning into the WWE I mean even the
UFC's now has merged with the WWE yeah
um everything is kind of you know you
have celebrities fighting boxes like
everything is kind of
merging in a weird way everything yeah
it's like and you think that's good or
bad I don't know that's the thing I
don't know what it is it's hard to get
it's hard for me I'm I have a tough time
seeing like the like the like the
patterns and a tough time seeing like
the bigger picture things so I'm like
what is kind of going on do we feel like
things are getting better or more unique
do we feel like we're just becoming like
I don't know America doesn't really feel
like a big thing anymore like when I was
like America was like the biggest thing
there was dude it was like the biggest
company in the world was America right
it was like we're the biggest company
we're the number one on the Dow Jones
baby yeah USA that was it but now it
feels almost and maybe it's just because
I live in California it it almost feels
like in and I this isn't a political
statement but it doesn't it feel weird
to rep America a little bit like if you
just see somebody wearing like a USA
t-shirt you almost look at them and you
and you you automatically associate who
they are politically and like who they
are and like how they eat [__] and like
how they shoot guns yeah they eat it
from the back yeah they're pulling hair
like it's a goddamn trucker but it feels
like
but like there's nothing wrong with you
it's like no there's nothing wrong at
all right because you'd see a guy then
uh with a Brazilian flag you're like
yeah that guy loves his country exactly
but thank you to see a guy with American
fight you're like oh this guy might be
some right-wing Politico guy yeah but
that dude could be sucking [__] like his
[__] you know on some Joey Chestnut
[__] you know so you don't really know
what or where or how or why but like
something about the USA flag you think
you know the person specifically well
that's when it starts to feel like that
something like there must be the dark
artists that kind of run things whoever
they are or if there is
they you know
they've definitely started to dissolve
the idea of what it means to be American
to a lot of people you know but at the
same time it's like you have people
expressing all their rights and opinions
when they're lucky enough to live in a
country where you can express your right
opinions it's a great place but it's
only because they those things have been
like fought for in
um the government has been kept enough
in check yeah and the you know thing
it's only because like because easily
you could be Cuba or you could be
um
what's another place
Europe Europe
Paris where they don't or you know what
I'm saying you could be another place
where you don't have the freedom yeah
yeah Russia dude my family's very
Russian and it's like I was I told
somebody the other day I was like I kind
of want to go back to like right now I
was like yeah what's up they're like
what do you mean what's up have you
heard of anything about Russian Ukraine
right now you dumbass I'm like dude I
get all my news from laffy taffies and
Snapchat I'm not doing well in the head
brother I don't know what to tell you
but like it might but like I think we
take it for granted [__] USA you know
but if you see a guy with a Ford F-350
and it's a wrapped USA you're like oh
this guy really means it this guy is on
a first name basis with a lot of Hooters
in town yeah yeah
well I definitely think there's like
some traditionalism but there are people
who like use the flag now also as like
I'm gonna use the flag as my way of
showing how
um
conservative I am or I don't know but
there's also like libert like people
that have Liberty or like what is the
new thing it's
libertarian libertarian do they use the
American flag a lot
I feel like they do I feel like they
think that's hilarious dude yeah that's
like [__] some people would have an
ozempic flag outside and people would be
knocking at the door like you got it I
heard a girl at a bar maybe a month ago
she goes I think I'm going to Mexico
next week because ozempic is 800 cheaper
and I was like that sends a loan and I
was just looking at I was like why do
you have to be so goddamn hot that's
like like if I said that people like
you're an idiot but I heard that and I
was like I could see through the red
flags on this but like going across the
border to get diabetic medicine so you
can look thinner it's a wild time yeah
so the same way that we might say like a
USA flag might look weird on somebody
because it's too patriotic dude they're
looking at La be like you you [__]
are addicted to diabetic medicine right
[__] yeah put it in your zins dude
let's fire up
yeah I don't know and most of our are
like the military that protects our
country or keeps things like
you know will protect us if need be they
are
they have the American flag on their
[__] uniform so it's really weird to
get people who are like against America
like why have we created a people that
are against our own flag that's the
[__] weird thing to me it is bizarre
it's like being like I [__] hate
Arby's but then you're doing work out at
Arby's yeah but you're wearing a big hat
yeah
you know it's like where did that come
from where are they getting off this
giant ass cowboy hat there's a comedian
they used to have that joke he was like
oh do you think Arby's is just a oh uh
do you think there's somebody who thinks
Arby's is just a place where they sell
big hats oh God that was an old joke
somebody had look at did you ever uh you
know what Arby stands for
Arby's roast beef yeah RB that's why
it's Arby's wow isn't that crazy that is
cool that's some [__] that blows my mind
more than it should
yeah that's the kind of [__] people
don't know who like the seventh
president was but they know that right
it's like when you're a child and they
do this got your nose and you're like
hold the [__] on yeah better slow down
there brother what are we doing here
yeah give me that back yeah when I found
out Arby's was Arby's like recently yeah
I didn't know a pickle and a cucumber
were the same thing until I was 22. oh
yeah it just blow your mind doesn't it
nobody tells you that yeah we'll learn
about Volvos and goddamn sexual ad dude
man with Jolly ranch remember when Jolly
Ranchers came out
dude I was thinking about uh my god do
you [__] remember it though
but do you remember I mean you you got
people because a candy never lasted that
long no I want to tell you that before
that they'd had [__] candies they'd
had mints and they'd had them
uh even when you break it down it's
still tough oh God you couldn't even
break it down you had to hire a man to
[__] almost chew on it for you a
little bit and then put it back in your
mouth God remember when uh Yogurtland
came out
not Yogurtland Pinkberry yeah Pinkberry
had the World by the goddamn sack and a
half and what happened it was tart
yogurt and everyone's like what the [__]
is this yeah our brains couldn't
comprehend it if it went under I think
they're still out there but like at the
time yeah I saw him right yeah they're
out there they are but but at the time
our brains were like why is this ice
cream tart yeah and the worlds couldn't
comprehend it it was like Burger King uh
chicken fries yeah so goddamn good and
they were paying we just said Brianna
chicken fry on actually oh nice yeah
yeah she's she's great yeah she's she's
interesting remember in Dallas a girl
this was like years and years ago maybe
like 2017 she DM me before the show she
goes you can pour uh chocolate sauce in
my titties and before I get off stage I
was like hold up before I get out of
here I remember this DM where's the
chocolate sauce titty girl and she's
like whoa and then we hooked up with
that night she had some fronzier bags on
her and I'm real talking aged like fine
wine great she DM me like maybe like six
months ago I was like thinking about you
I was thinking about them
God but something like that like that's
a DM where you're like I can't not not
answer this yeah
yeah sometimes it's cool if you have a
chick just kind of lean off the bed and
hang one tit off the bed man like it's
looking for an iPhone charger yeah
you think if you're a female you'd have
more ass or more rack dude I think if I
were a female I would just uh uh
probably leave the house I'd probably
get nipples put onto my butt cheeks and
just go all tits no ass all tits no ass
yeah wow wow that would
well tits no ass you had that just
unlimited tits I kind of like it because
it's uh it comes around you know like up
front frontal appearance people are like
yeah whatever that's just the Ivana
whatever your name is and then you walk
away and they're like oh damn I've
misspoken you know because up front
you're just chilling then on the back
you got that Hemi if you saw that brawl
in somebody's ass you'd be like my God
they're doing that well it's like a
Lamborghini you got the engine in the
back yeah got the Hemi up on those legs
I love that man it's funny you know it's
cool that people have an ass and tits
man both what do you got Zach what's up
in the news of it there for you
we were watching this video
um this girl did a she recreated Kobe
Bryant she's an Asian woman
um she changed her face to look like
Kobe Bryant and it's pretty well crazy
he's gonna need to see that and then so
there's debate is this black face or not
you tell me
um
yeah I mean immediately yes no you think
I will say this this looks like a lot of
the portraits that you've seen drawn of
Kobe around town
what I haven't seen really many good
portraits of Kobe which is [__] up
given how great he he was let's see her
one more time
this is like Kobe Bryant he saw him on
like Hollywood Boulevard she looks like
Charlemagne in like 20 years I feel like
do you think this is considered
blackface not to me it's not
it's might be considered Laker face
you know what I'm saying or Western
Conference phase but I don't think this
is black how do you I mean dude this is
I mean how do you not run this past one
person
you're Asian dude some Asians don't even
talk to each other dude if you've been
to China bro it's 70 billion people not
even talking to each other that's crazy
it's unbelievable I feel like that's how
my brain works it's like 70 billion
thoughts but nobody's aligned nobody's
connecting nobody's you know running
past each other what are people saying
are they into this or not uh I don't
think so I mean first of all it has 16
million views 17 million views I mean if
that's what you got to do to get those
views I mean people are saying it's
blackface well here's what I think she's
gonna be on the Nook boys podcast
tomorrow yeah at a certain point black
like
blackface was can you show down a little
it was they were doing it because they
didn't black people weren't allowed to
be actors so they painted white people
as black people
oh I didn't know that
she's trying to look like Kobe how else
would she do it
no uh and then someone said I feel like
she's just displaying her makeup or
Talent blackface is really a reach here
yeah maybe that's what I think this
looks a little artistic I don't know it
kind of uncomforts me if a kid who
really loves a black athlete can't be
though I mean I guess you can just by
having this jersey yeah but like if they
wanted to like because a kid if he has
no malice in him and he's not trying to
like do anything bad I don't know at a
certain point
uh
yeah I think people if you have the
Jersey people still don't get the gist
nobody's wearing just the Kobe jersey
and they're like I don't believe you
then just pass them a can of pain like
you know to do yeah mean it
but then here's the crazy part there'll
be some black people like oh you ain't
[__] real bro unless you paint
yourself up
you know the next thing you know the guy
can't win yeah the guys yeah that's the
thing you can't really win because
there's always that party that's like oh
there's always that part of Black
Culture that's like oh you ain't real
enough you know unless you go all the
way in and then there's always that part
of the culture that's like oh this is
too much bro you [__] uh using
cultural appropriate I think if she
wanna you just go half she could just do
half yeah there you go you know that way
like if somebody's like that's offensive
she turns like this and like what do you
mean like ah but then the crowd that's
like oh that's not folding a boom yeah
kind of like a flounder and she's Asian
if it were a white person maybe it gets
looked at a little bit differently this
person is an Asian person they don't
know what they're doing she doesn't even
know Kobe Bryant passed away yeah she
probably doesn't and also is this Kobe
Bryant let's look at this [__] first
it looks more like
um maybe like Ron our test after he's
been doing a lot of Equinox yeah
yeah I would say that it looks more like
uh I mean yeah the more look at this
just doesn't look anything like Kobe
Bryant right this looks like have you
ever seen a good Kobe Bryant mural now
they're all a little off huh right
that would piss me off yeah this looks
like right yeah I think you're right on
the run our test it even
I don't even know who this looks like a
black like a black guy that would work
like in an office or something like a
FedEx brother do you ever seen that guy
hooping at a gym and he's wearing all
Michael Jordan head to toe it kind of
looks like a little bit there should be
a video he's like hooping out like a 24
Hour Fitness
what else we got Zach for the news
um California is about to ban Skittles
really other candies yeah oh this is
interesting yeah apparently they're kind
of toxic I [__] love so Skittles Pez
Hot Tamales
um this is gonna happen and many more
popular candies the California Assembly
last week or only the past assembly Bill
418 sending the legislation over to
State Senate
um as long as I'm banned Tech talk I
don't really give a [__] with a band
Skittles is just funny it's like we have
Vape flavored Skittles Hot Tamales too
though well I guess they have link
they're linked to cancer that's a big
thing Skittles I mean allegedly that's
why this is all is this Our Generations
putting Coke and Coke back in the day
you know
like was there cancer in the Skittles
and they knew it or whatever yeah what
if
I mean I think I'm like this is just
something's just change over time you
know if the chemicals are bad then
they're bad who knows
what's Skittle slogan
Taste the rainbow oh well we should get
rid of that first before we do anything
yeah especially on the on the heels of
all the remember all the Bud Light stuff
which has been so crazy for them are
they doing like a camo can to like
combat it yeah I think they just do both
it's camo rainbow a rainbow camo and
just they [__] the fruit it would look
like a four logo honestly yeah
I miss a good four Loco it's crazy how
many but then also the craziest thing
about the Bud Light thing is all they
did was send that girl some beers right
or that guy Dylan I don't even know what
happened they sent him some views you
know like sometimes like Brands will
send you stuff and of course put your
name water or try to make it
personalized to you so that you'll share
it or make it a social thing that's what
they did that's all they did yeah
but mulvani took it and said oh they
made me a spot like Mulvane is the one
who blew it up all they did was send a
little gift thing what did the kid they
paid mulvani or not what did the can
look like or that was the one that's it
right there oh wait wait I didn't know
what the can look like for some reason I
thought it would uh
huh yeah that's it they just put her
picture on a can so she then blows it up
and then people you know now it's just
so much bigger than what they like it
unbelievable joke is so much bigger than
what it actually was the only person it
really behooved was um
perm
yeah and I'm Dylan probably made a lot
of money off this and we're just
exposure of course
yeah yeah I believe that he's a gay male
that's looking for clout but I don't
know if that definitely it's just
something that I believe and I could be
wrong
what do you think is that
um yeah I don't know I mean uh the thing
is people people thought that this was
being distributed Nationwide and no it
wasn't and it wasn't so it's kind of a
perfect example of like misinformation
like people didn't take any time to like
read into it further it just the joke
was so much bigger than the actual story
that now like anytime you see somebody
drinking a Bud Light oh better keep my
pants on or if I'm down for you know
like
you could buy somebody a Bud Light if
it's getting laid and you think they're
gay yeah I mean now now it's like it's
past the point of a controversy we know
it's just like funny at Bud Light
there's nothing to do with Dylan it's
more just like like it's funny like send
a a group of dudes on a bachelor party
or a Buffalo Wild Wings but hey can we
send around a Bud Lights and then they
get in they're like oh what I guess we
gotta suck each other off now just start
going after like it's funnier now than
the actual the the controversy I think
yeah I agree yeah I agree it's almost
just funny now it's like a funny thing
it's exactly crazy how quickly something
goes from being like real serious to
funny now it's like it used to be that
that probably would have taken two years
well now it's just the the name Bud
Light is a joke in the same way that the
name like Kyle or like Chad or some of
these big or Karen these big meme names
yeah are just forever Implement
implanted that like like so now you'll
never think of a Bud Light again the
same yeah and we'll be 93 in our chairs
with demand she'd be like [__] bud
light and just talking to a brick wall
you know Benjamin's gay you know or just
run our laps in our head of thoughts
what else we got Zach what else is going
on I can tell you this last night I was
at a fireplace in a moth landed on the
corner and then he just flew directly
into the fire I was like you were
looking for the wrong light brother he's
his time was done I saw him laying I was
like damn he's awfully close to the fire
he contemplated it maybe like four
seconds and then just be lined right
into the Flames wow it's kind of kind of
sad but honestly I respect it yeah well
I mean I think it's a lot of people how
like addiction happens it's like you
once and you feel it makes you feel warm
it's a good light and you're like I'm
going all the way in think about that
he's like I'm [__] done with light
bulbs give me the brightest hottest [__]
you can find I want all that smoke yeah
God kind of respect him a little bit I'm
gonna get them tattooed on my bicep yeah
mothy
um dude I saw one time I was in church
and a woman
um a butterfly came and landed on her
face at church really and she said oh
that's my son he visits me every year he
died this time like seven years ago
so uh it was at this Crystal Cathedral
in Orange California and the doors of
the church open like the whole wall
opens so that
um butterfly so that like uh you can
just the organ is like right there and
it's just beautiful it's oh wow and this
butterfly came all the way in and landed
right on her cheek and she that's what
she said that's my son he died in a
motorcycle accident and uh he comes and
visits me well I would start tearing up
on spot it was crazy man I got some
pictures with her I got a good look and
see if I have no real pictures yeah
taking some pictures like this and she
just got the butterfly did the butterfly
ever come to you at all or no it kind of
haul it meant it stayed on her face for
probably about 15 minutes wow and then
it left that'd be cool if you and the
Butterfly became boys just left right
out the same way it came in yeah could
be interesting yeah videos like that
would make me tear up also uh yeah
when's the last time you teared up you
think oh man probably recently yeah you
know it's a lot of stuff in my personal
life and just kind of just figure I'm
just trying to figure out like what and
who I am I guess I like I know very much
career-wise but I think internally
you know like I'm 30 and I'm like I
don't have a family I don't really know
what's going on and it's like sure I can
drown my life out with work and you know
I can always be like I have more tour
dates make more videos edit this but
it's like it's this moments where I'm
sitting still I'm like what
what am I doing this for who who would I
want to share this with you know damn I
don't know not to get deep but it but I
know it's important part like that or or
if I see a video of like uh you know
somebody coming home from the war and
surprising their son at a baseball field
that'll give me um dude come in home
every time that or it's like the The Wiz
Khalifa song
those always make me cry those are those
man or like the dad walks into the
baseball or uh to the classroom oh I
watch those anytime I need to adjust my
feelings dude those are the videos that
I go to those always make me feel just
feel I just feel right there yeah those
are great you know videos I love
watching for the opposite reasons is
stolen valid videos you ever seen those
in the airport when the guy's like
filming he's like oh you serve too nice
where'd you serve at and you guys like
uh St Petersburg and the guy's like
really because if you did be on your
left shoulder it starts going Adam and
then he's like so the Valor the guy just
trying to get a free Cinnabon at the
airport I [__] God it's so it's such
a loser thing to do oh it's the when
people do Stolen Valor they shouldn't
make them have to do a week of boot camp
Oh that's like that's their punishment
dude the videos are just so funny
because it's like what are you trying to
do it for they always look like a guy at
the top left yeah it's always at a
restaurant too restaurant or the airport
because they're trying to get like a
free meal or something oh yeah that's
what they're using it for yeah that'll
like respect or something like board the
plane first that's just too many hacks
man if you're hacking the world this
much you gotta shut it down bro yeah
it's just I don't know man it's there's
better ways to do it like don't wear
like like I would just wear a t-shirt
says like organ donor somebody will help
you out yeah that's a good point and
that's not storm Valor if you aren't
maybe it is the craziest Stolen Valor is
when you see somebody wearing like a uh
Travis Kelsey Jersey and they're not
it's like and they're not Travis Scott
chance bro
yeah but the video is always so funny
because they you can tell they did their
research up to a certain point but
they're not even as healthy as Randy
Travis yeah right bring up Randy Travis
yeah I just it's they're so funny to me
and God bless Randy Travis is an amazing
singer
um he has a disability what is it called
he's got something men uh oh I didn't
know that
Lu uh what's he got Lou uh Lou Gehrig's
maybe Lou Gehrig's yeah
or somebody garrig's what's he got he
had a stroke oh he had a stroke
my bad but he's got yeah yeah but if you
see somebody in a rant yeah in a Travis
Kelsey Jersey and they're not even
Travis Kelsey they're not yet and
they're not even Randy they're not even
like you know they're not even Travis
Pastrana yeah and he's deceased didn't
he no no you know he's just he's a lot
yeah he's he's very yeah so they uh so
anyway that kind of stuff to me is some
real Stolen Valor what makes you laugh
or what makes you cry well let's do both
sides
well I mean what you're saying I think
about like not knowing like what's going
like what am I doing this for [__] dude
that [__] can
I find my emotions get really high like
that and then I kind of calm myself down
I'm like it doesn't matter what if I
don't know the answers today that's fine
and then I can like walk myself through
but it starts off high then I like walk
myself through it yeah and then I saw
that moth it goes straight into that
fire I was thinking about this last
night actually I saw a moth go right
into the fire and I was like damn
maybe that's
I don't know everybody has their own
Journey whoa whoa brother that moth was
not feeling it but yeah I don't know I I
think that's I I usually feel that and
then I can walk myself through it
that's the thing if you don't get an
idea of what you want to do then
whatever you're doing will just continue
I noticed that for myself it's like I
work all the time I mean last night I'm
messaging Zach at freaking midnight
about something yeah you know and you
just can't shut the brain off I'm the
same way and I'm so so thankful that I
knew what I wanted to do at a young age
like I the fact that I'm more lost in
life than I am with career it's a
blessing because the other ways it can
can be just it's just a different way
but yeah I mean it's always greener it's
like you have the perfect family
relationship but you're [__] you know
you work at H R Block and you're like I
want it to be a balloon animal artist
yeah and now you're in the bathroom
blowing up goddamn Trojans making snakes
oh yeah drug muelling dude yeah so I
don't know I I don't think I ever have
to know what's really going on you just
take it day by day oh yeah dude I think
sometimes bruh uh but I notice if you
don't have an idea or get an idea at
some point you'll just continue like I
just continue to work my life continues
to be kind of the same cycle some of it
is because like
of like just being late to figuring out
what's going on with myself you know
whereas now as I do start to look a bit
a little bit more like I want a family
or I'm alone by myself and it's like man
after a while this gets boring right you
know or uh you want to have somebody to
share like a nice time with you know but
then you have a family you go to
Disneyland all of a sudden some dude's
swinging on you yeah and then you're
like God I wish I was [__] single so
there's no you know there's no perfect
way there isn't and that's what I think
you find out just the time you just find
out what you like what you don't like
and you try to tend towards you like as
much as you can yeah do you think you
would ever leave your wife and children
definitely
respect would you ever leave your wife
and kids I believe that if I don't want
to
I'm gonna say that right now I do not
want to leave you guys
whoever they are yeah and I
did I used to write postcards to my kids
like that like years ago I'd write
postcards I can't even though I didn't
even have them where would you send them
just to my own address and like save
them for my kids from when I get older
or whatever that's crazy right did you
have their names already picked out or
it'd be like insert name I can't
remember if I put their names first I
think I just put dear name here yeah uh
yeah I can't remember or unborn or
something like [__] weird yeah yeah
but because I think part of me always
wanted probably to have children but I I
could never see any way how I was gonna
get there from where I was where I was
at well what happens with me I was with
a couple recently and they've been
together for five years they got a kid
on the way and hearing them talk made me
realize how far away I am from where
they are in life you know they're like
oh we're getting married next year we
just had a kid and like the way they
would talk like she would start talking
and then he'd be like do you want should
I finish the story because you're
telling me wrong I'll finish the story
then they're like going back they're
like arguing with each other and they
bring it to you and like I was so
disconnected to where those two were at
in life of a family and like it you know
if a family was like a like a pie chart
like they had so much more pie than me
like I had just a little sliver yeah you
were morale mode huh yeah I was on the
side I was a little I was a little
raspberry on the side just hanging out
well I think but also for some people
there's different paths you know and
it's hard to battle with whatever your
path has been you know it's like I felt
like when I was a kid like I just didn't
have like a lot of affection and stuff
at home but then as an adult like you
were saying I got a lot more like
affection is from strangers you know so
it's almost like you just never really
know what the path for life is gonna be
that's true you know you might like
Robert Downey Johnson or whatever just
had a kid at 79 years old right De Niro
Robert De Niro did it really yeah backed
up down there I know he just had a kid
man wow yeah Robert well how old your
dad was old my dad was 70 yeah so you
were doing so he was following the
footsteps of your father yeah I mean my
dad I mean this is nine years later
that's crazy I remember my dad would
tell me stories about kids in his
village like eating dirt they were
starving yeah you know his old village
is crazy
um there he is right there yeah he's
still pumping is that his wife and he's
hammering on that mixed yam homie yeah
look at that's his lady oh yeah gang
maybe damn
I feel like after he busts one he does
like he like hops on his glasses
and then like polishes on like a silk
t-shirt yeah what's the oh that's good
what's the best post
uh ejaculate uh move
uh I would say finger pistols or a
Gainer flip into a hot tub
in the flip where you run back one too
what is that that's a forward-facing
backflip oh that's crazy if you come and
then just do a gander flip into a body
of water you get Knocked Up and that sun
is addicted to vape early oh dude here's
the crazy thing these days somebody who
can do a forward backflip like you're
saying is looked at more prestigiously
than somebody who's serving in the
military oh dude I mean if I see you do
that you're in my will I don't give a
[__] you earn part of what I earned
forever you're more important than my
agent and manager
bro it's so crazy how one little thing
that somebody can do yeah what's the
craziest thing I think uh oh one thing
that's crazy is if you say I'm going to
the restroom you go hide in their
apartment it's just anywhere yeah just
in the pantry eating hibiscus well you
hide and that's gonna look for you like
oh it's hiding this one person is a
[__] psycho I'm definitely taking
Plan B after this person and then you
forgot it's your apartment and they just
leave them for seven hours what do you
think what do you think a girl would get
the most turned on like what move do you
think you could do though like oh my God
Theo's
so much more attractive than I thought
like what's a movie besides hiding I
don't know I don't have a lot of strong
moves I think it's kind of like the
Wi-Fi maybe kissing on the neck a little
bit I like yeah on you or you to her me
to her I like kissing on a woman neck
probably yeah unless she got too much
[Music]
um
perfume on there oh yeah God dang some
ladies put that [__] on bro right your
tongue goes numb you got fentanyl on
your neck I know damn bro some lady that
[__] is too much bro that's a little
heavy but I like it the next day if like
the pillow kind of smells like her
that's some [__] where I'm like nice
that's my wife that's white stuff that's
how like like I uh I met up with uh my
ex a couple months after we had broken
up and that scent was the same scent and
it brought back so many memories just
like it's just it's just associate you
know yeah we had a chick at our school
they used to go to school and she put
that orange bathroom cleaner you know
that smell that's in all the bathrooms
fabulosa oh no no no no no it was just
very generic orange bathroom cleaner I
think it was called out too generic
orange bathroom cleaner yeah something
just like that by Nabisco yeah yeah it
was a government scent and she she put
that [__] on oh Ajax and I would smell
it no no this is way too commercialized
a lot of that uh
and she'll put it on yeah wow wow maybe
that was it up one smelling like
vitamins and to the left
something like that Eco orange yeah yeah
she put that [__] Eco orange on at
school I like the scent of the the pink
soap they got in the schools that
stuff's good that stuff was nice it
tastes like uh like a like like
Robitussin oh you're not supposed to
taste it
but I used to Huff a lot of things as a
child
God yeah there you go right there get
that the one yeah yeah that's the stuff
we're looking at yeah that would like
the scent to that reminds me of the
dentist office but like in a good way
Advantage chemicals it was called dude
they did not put any [__] work into
that name like it's a contest dude
Advantage chemicals you just knew you're
gonna lose that's not a crime scene you
pulled over a dead body and the body
just disintegrates oh that's a Dexter
sauce I mean that's all that is what
other news we got there's a ton of
Stories on there can I go pee real quick
yeah let's go piss man take a break
what else you've been dating what have
you been doing because last time we saw
each other we went to Young gravies
remember oh yeah yeah I saw you with
young gravy I was uh seeing a lady at
that point
um yeah I'm kind of just trying to
figure things out right now I'm really
just uh I'm filming a special in July so
I'm really just trying to focus on
everything just comedy related right now
just but uh it's hard because you know
you like you said you're like man I like
going on dates is fun it's like it's fun
kind of building up you know chemistry
with people see if it's working or not
and whatnot but
um sometimes yeah you just like you have
a show and like you meet a really cool
chick and you're like all right let's
feel this out like sometimes you don't
even want to date but somebody gets
brought into your life and you're like
oh let me explain let me see what's
going on here
um do you have a process for not wasting
your time and their time a little bit
uh I think I'm getting
um I don't know I like you do a call
first usually you do anything like that
or you just kind of
um no I wish do you I know some people
like FaceTime before but that's so weird
it feels weird but if it saves everybody
the time that's true I don't know if I
have a plan I should have a better plan
I need to start to have a plan I think
if I want to get a wife and family like
not that I I can choose what's gonna
happen because you don't know what's
going to happen right but I think I
should have at least like some uh
a little bit of a like a pattern I'd
like to follow to help myself yeah I
kind of feel it out just like you kind
of feel it like through texting like
what type of person that is but like
some people talk to they're they got it
all mapped out I don't have like that
they're like first date you go to drinks
it's an easy and it's an easy out second
date Park free cheap get out third date
then you have food it's like it's all my
app I kind of just feel it out yeah like
I'll take a girl to a steakhouse four
minutes in and I'll be like
we don't need to be here yeah you know
or she'll say something she's like oh we
could have just watched the sunset
you're like that shit's free
you're like steak mistake God damn send
this back it's medium rare send me back
uh I don't really have a process I don't
know I don't really know what's going on
in life a lot of times really
um yeah I think it's well it's just
interesting especially these days I
think
we're also like on social media we're
all on like we're constantly being
entertained by stuff right correct
there's so much entertainment like you
can turn on your phone at any point you
can see like an amazing goal being
scored someone uh battling something
severe in their life somebody uh doing a
GoFundMe somebody lost their arms legs
and head I saw the other day some guy
lost his arms legs and head you can also
watch a man getting head in a thing yeah
and you can do GoFundMe for both it's
crazy how much stimulation your brain is
thrown at you all at once it's the best
of everything right all in a few minutes
but then you shut it off and you come
back to whatever your regular life is
and usually I think in that time when
your brain would have been kind of
processing what's going on in your own
life because your brain's kind of a
processor right it wants to organize
things of course your brain wants to
organize things like that's its like
modus operandi like that's it's what it
does it like notices patterns it
organizes things so you have the best
most comfortable way to live and survive
right that's like what is whole job is
yeah so I think usually
when we're relaxing or resting or giving
our brain time to kind of process and
we're not just constantly entertaining
that's what it is then we are able to
have more things figured out whereas I
think now when we're just doing constant
entertainment you're not getting as much
figured out like in the background
your brain a chance to openly think
that's why you got to return the books
it's like you know at the library you
see all the stacks of books that were
returned yep and you're like damn this
my the book I really like could be in
there but I don't even know yeah we're
not giving our brain a chance to return
any books we're just [__] opening up
millions of [__] books there's
anything on the Shelf anymore exactly
tons of books and throwing books of the
show and they fall right off yeah yeah
Dewey Decimal is shooting up in the
[__] in the corner like long division
hasn't been talking to in a long time
that boy turned an academy in asap down
by the Hudson but that's really kind of
a neat analogy I didn't think about that
before but that's kind of what it's like
it is because all those thoughts are in
your brain but you you're just you're
distracting it with social media and I
mean it's it is wild and that's why like
people [__] lose their mind you know
on a plane before you can't take off and
there's no like there's no like Wi-Fi
yet or you can't open up your laptop the
dark 11 they call it that dark 11. oh do
they yeah yeah but that's who you are in
that 11 minutes is who you really are
yeah who you are when your phone is dead
that's who you really are when you're
just sitting there at an IHOP with a
dead phone and you got to make eye
contact with the lady with one eye yeah
I'll take the flapjack and what the [__]
happened there but like those moments
it's like I did that last night when I
was sitting by the fireplace I I didn't
have my phone and I just wanted to just
I just wanted to
I've been traveling so much I kind of
like lost
my own narrative a little bit and I just
was like what what is important right
now what do I want to focus on
I just stared Into the Fire and it's
just like
oh I had every thought that I've been
neglecting it felt nice it's kind of
like when people do mushrooms it's like
those thoughts get brought to the
surface yeah I'm trying to think one of
my favorite times on mushrooms ever
um I like being on a bird scoot or a
little buzz oh and I know that's illegal
but it feels [__] is it illegal I
feel like they only work if you have a
buzz dude I remember when we were as uh
children they had we did some uh LSD or
mushrooms right or um one of the two
or LSD and we went to the Waffle House
and it was the first time we'd seen a
gay dude right or a ledge gay or
whatever at Waffle House yeah or just in
general uh I can't remember but it was
the first time we'd seen a gay dude like
this close to like a kitchen right and
it was uh they had
um
it was like the first time we'd seen
like a gay dude with like a menu you
know okay so uh my buddy started just
laughing so hard we were just on drug
like we were laughing so hard the guy
thought that he was choking right
because of how he was laughing like he
was like laughing so much he was like
almost spitting up yeah so he starts
doing the Heimlich maneuver on my buddy
a dude that we had just thought was gay
so now the whole restaurant was like
what's going on here let's don't say
restaurant
this is where like this is normal Waffle
House Behavior there's no this is where
people and in our town like they had a
long bridge near our town it was the
longest bridge in the world for a while
and it dropped off one end of it was by
our town nice and the um so the police
everybody they caught on that bridge
drunk uh drive and they would drop off
at this Waffle House so it was like a
[__] that was your drunk tank was a
Waffle House yeah I mean if I was drunk
I would definitely stay so it was like a
boost smart yeah it was a Booz Zoo for
[__]
just just derelicts you know so anyway
this but this alleged gay dude is just
[__] heimlich at my buddy who's not
she already coughed up and he's still
gone oh dog he's good he's good they
just turn out and I'm like is this dude
really an EMT or is this dude just
having like kind of like a fit of gay or
whatever you know but he was humping on
my home yeah Waffle House you walk in
they're sober but you sit in that chair
long enough you feel a little bit you
don't know what drug it is yeah if it's
an upper or down or just life but you
feel that oh it's that [__] margarine
Buzz homie I [__] love Waffle House
there was a donut shop in my hometown
where uh if you used to flash them your
tits you get free donuts
I never did it for me but they did have
God I love that but like I was always
wondering like like do they do a buy
size like what if you showed your tits
and like all right here's a donut hole
I'd be like damn I got fake tits for no
reason but yeah like if you had some
knockers they'd be like here's a bear
claw it's kind of crazy oh that was the
original girl has gone wild
God I'd show my oh God I don't know what
I'm looking for a bear call when I was a
kid so good in our neighborhood if you
had respect for something you'd take
your shirt off yeah what is that it's
just like a thing it's almost very
native I think you would Alpha yeah or
no not Alpha just like you wanted them
to like it was a sign of respect like a
standing ovation but for your body yeah
because I think back in the day we
didn't have clothes on all the time
that's true who invented clothes can you
look it up
some [__] idiot probably that's what
I'm saying you want to see less tit
unless it was like a parent then I get
it but like yeah the Neanderthals oh
Ronnie pants did it huh the first known
humans to make clothing Neanderthal man
survived from about 200 000 BC to about
30 000. wow 170 000 years do they do it
because they were cold or they were just
too horny during this time maybe tried
celibacy and he's like bro you got to
cut those nips up or something
during this time the Earth temperature
Rosen fell dramatically creating a
series of ice ages throughout the
Northern areas
um when was the first clothing made can
you go down to that who was the first
boss 200 000 BCE that's what they said
okay and what was it can we look and see
what it was you gotta be like a leaf
the First clothes were made from natural
elements animal skin and Furs grasses
and leaves and bones and shells
um it was often draped or tied
however simple needles made out of
animal bone provided evidence of sewn
leather and fur garments from at least
30 000 years ago
did they even have yeah I'm trying to
think if you could stunt back then you
think you could 100 I think so
because how do you roll up when do you
roll up
not in the middle of the day it's hot as
hell right because somebody's in a cave
like you have to like when when he Flex
in it
probably if I was you know I would do I
would I'm gonna go get some water right
go to the well no clothes not come back
with the water and the clothes and
they'd be like oh my God I'm like oh
yeah oh oh this oh the water the outfit
you know like a little like subtle like
yeah which one yeah this one's dripping
you know which one got that water shoddy
who who what now the town caveman I
don't know when would you do it I don't
that's a good question bro I think if
you roll in around dinner with a special
deal like a little dessert or a little
yeah for dessert yeah fruit or something
you bring a [__] Apple they've never
seen
everybody's smashing bro and dude back
in the day there was no way to let
people know you were happy except
they're probably jerk off you think oh
I'm sure if you brought the figures or
like the what the [__] it called Kmart
dude hieroglyphics no somebody what do
you think maybe if you're stuck in a
room you're stuck in a cave right you're
in there by fire and somebody brings out
an apple and you've never [__] seen
one you take a bite of it oh that would
that would that would do things to me I
still feel that way a cold Granny Smith
I would take that over sex a lot of days
call Granny Smith a little bit of peanut
butter on It come on now she'll never
leave you unread
do you DM a lot of like girls that you
think are attractive or you no I usually
wait until people like DM me um because
I'm so scared of rejection that like I
have sent like a DM to like like a hot
chick that I thought was like pretty
cute or something yeah and it [__] with
my ego because if I hit them up and they
don't respond then I'm like oh all right
maybe I'm just invisible and who knows
she maybe is dating somebody or she's
not into a super sexy buff guys like me
like who knows what the flaw is yeah but
what about you do you I said let me
think I sent Bruce Willis's doll and his
daughter's a DM one time and she didn't
write me back but how did that did that
do anything for your ego or were you
just like damn no I saw her at a party
and I'd seen her before I decided oh
yeah I just wish it was really neat and
had just uh that's a rejection for me uh
you know visually I was very you know
remember what you said stimulated why
she didn't say anything no what did you
say I said oh good evening
um I said oh good evening there's bugs
in here I said oh good evening
uh uh all right what do you say oh damn
he's got a lot of them I should have
went through the catalog
I didn't know did I had uh somebody will
get back to you
rumor
yeah yeah that's her name rumor yeah
that's crazy yeah beautiful oh she you
know attractive lady I don't know her
that well but she just had uh uh I just
saw her somewhere and yeah so then uh
Center Indian but but that's okay it's
like you know that's life what are you
gonna do it is and you don't know why
they didn't respond or whatever he
married her dad has been sick she also
may have zero interest to me she may uh
not even you don't know yeah it could be
anything dude you're basically just
throwing
you're just wishing into the world
that's really what it is yeah and it's
kind of for like a date or get to know
somebody
um
so I don't know that's pretty that's
okay though right who are the people
you're dating are there people you kind
of meet out and about or are these
you know let me think
um
uh a gal that I met at a comedy show
okay but the tough thing is yeah you
start to look at your schedule you start
to look what that's like you start to
look at your own Ambitions yeah like uh
you know David Spade and I are trying to
get that movie done and not to name drop
but people know that and that's what
we've been working on and so it's like
that's awesome well if I have to go do
that how long does that take and then
yeah you know people keep at or I want
to go tour more so that's probably going
to be the rest of this year and next
year yeah I feel insane when the girls
like we should get drink sometime I'm
like yeah are you free in four months I
know you're like sick she's like no and
if I am I'm dating somebody else yeah
but in some weird way you're like okay
that's when I'm like here or something
do you ever do uh Chocolate Sundaes at
the Laugh Factory they book you for a
first impression but it's like two and a
half years before they're like are you
available in 2048 and you're like yeah
if I'm not dead I'll be there for my
three minutes but I remember like 2015 I
signed up for it and thank God it took
so long because I was trash then
probably slightly less trash when I did
it but like ended up doing well and you
got past and everything but it's like it
was like a two and a half year wait yeah
it's just so funny to be like are you
available for this you're like huh who
has plans for that oh so I'm gonna be
enlisted for that my bad yeah that's the
future man the future is so weird
because it's like
we know it exists
but we don't
the future just like a moving walkway in
the mall it's just gonna keep going no
matter who's on it or who's off of it
it's just going
the future is so because we know so much
about it based on what we know from the
past you know like are we assume that's
the thing about the future film yeah
it's this big bowl of assumption you
know yeah it's this [__] grandiose
play of assumption
so we've assumed exactly what's going to
have based on everything that's happened
but then that's the goal I think that's
the dope ass thing that the future can
do right if the future is a [__] real
Vibe right if he's like Trick Daddy or
something oh he's got a couple tricks up
at sleep yeah you know all flying cars
no here's a flashlight you're like I'm
not mad that's kind of worse it's kind
of better than a flying car
you ever use the flashlight uh nope I
never have man have you ever used it I
have it sad the pose is not blank after
it's full or whatever
what is that crazy or whatever no my
little robot for my cat does that though
oh it does yeah after I come into the
little robot no
um but it's the post-nut regret is
insane because you have to clean it out
and you're like in a sink there's dishes
you haven't watched in three weeks and
you're just in there scrubbing away you
catch a glimpse of yourself in like an
old [__] shiny cup looking at you did
you take it to the cleaners or whatever
uh you could probably put it outside and
like water it down there has to be a
place to mail it or something you know I
think prison they'd be pretty happy with
that
dude we really want to get an inmate if
anybody knows an inmate or has a
familial inmate uh we would love to have
a pen pal I think in here oh a pen pal
would be cool and preferably I would
love for them I don't want to say what
they're in for but tell me you know I'll
do really
give me a clue yeah we're gonna do a
little yeah a little miming there yeah
yeah a little game of Clue right I feel
like it has to be a good crime huh yeah
definitely because I feel like even I
mean I would just be so curious to even
talk to someone who's ever murdered
somebody I know I've always wanted to
but the crazy thing is we probably have
due to the [__] Juice Shop hey are
you next in line oh yeah cool this guy's
killed somebody yeah
you go first have you ever talked to
someone who's killed somebody oh yeah
dude I got a butt I got a friend who
killed somebody on purpose
um
I don't want to say well good legal
reasons but he's yeah honestly bro and
he's he said it's all he said it's
it's awesome
well I think we know why he did it
why I don't know but like if you're like
was it on accident or not and he said it
was awesome I don't think any accidents
are awesome he said it was awesome now
now you have to know him and know what
other stuff I think he thinks is awesome
right you have to have your own idea of
what is awesome you know you have to be
like uh you know if you could be a
stunning Steve Austin fan Did anyone say
that this is awesome was that him
um so I think there's a lot of elements
that can go into that but is he in jail
or no
he is
or we don't have to get into that yeah I
don't want to snitch I don't want to sit
I don't want I don't want him coming
after me that's all I'm saying it was an
accident he's he's vibing you know
what else can we talk about what else do
we have in the News Zach
um a German surgeon was fired because he
had a janitor help with an amputation
because no one was available that's
Health Care bro German surgeon fired
they getting anybody
I saw something recently maybe you can
try this there's a dude that got fired
at a hotel a manager snuck into
somebody's room and sucked their foot I
was in Nashville bring that up was that
really yeah Bobby did you did you talk
about it already or no no never talked
about it this was in Nashville yeah does
that resonate living there for a couple
years now
oh wow so you can guess toe's a sort of
nightmare let's go to the
oh that's somebody who's had a toe or
two in his taste buds yeah David Patrick
Neal three first names 52 was arrested
Friday after a hotel guest Peter Brennan
a walk around 5 a.m March ready to find
the night manager indulging his apparent
foot fetish
wow what does it say he did Brennan
reportedly screamed when he found Neil
sucking on his toes and immediately
recognized him as one of the two Hotel
staff members who had been in his room
the previous day to help him with his TV
first of all if you call a man from the
front desk come help you with your team
what are you you're kind of asking for
it you are giving low-key you're giving
low-key gay you're giving a lot of
low-key gay you're giving a lot of like
oh maybe you could come in and suck my
toes because think about it he was in
his room oh my TV doesn't work he's
probably has his shoes off the night
manager is like yeah okay what do you
want to watch yeah TNT no let me see
them Tian feet yeah yeah any kind of
song like dabbling right there wiggling
he's appointing oh the remotes over
there yeah like that's all it takes man
what else does it say anything else Zach
let's see some more information huh did
you go to jail for that are you just
horny Camp all my life you just have
this insecurity and that and that sense
of peace right it's not like you're
camping and you have to kind of keep one
eye open you have a security that's
yours when you close your eyes you feel
like you're safe and you're protected it
was a complete violation
who are you why are you in my room it
was almost like a dream
upon further investigation Brennan's
attorney uh found that Neil had a
lengthy rap sheet that included
voluntary manslaughter conviction for
shooting his roommate during a fight in
96. well the toe sucker shot someone
yeah wow so he's grown since then
he has
would you do if you were asleep in a
hotel Nashville someone was sucking on
your toes I mean look I'll say this it's
hard to get a foot off
okay so maybe the dude is just really
he needed that you know as somebody who
wasn't breastfed as a child and he just
needed some suck I think you got to let
him go for a little bit yeah I would
because what's gonna happen next like
where do you go from that yeah was your
toenail gonna grow a little bit
I would let yeah I'll give him a few
I'll do like two or three like oh no
what are you doing because then I could
also see if I'm into it right he's
already gonna assume you're already
gonna make Bank you might as well dabble
and see if you're into the you know yeah
the foot fantasies
trying to think of anything like that's
ever happened around uh I walked into a
room one night and uh there was a big
guy sitting on the bed already picking
his feet when I walked into my room they
gave me the wrong room and how did you
say anything or just oh I'm sorry I
didn't turn I did that backed out yeah
respected what he was doing understood
it about 4 15 in the afternoon I get it
picking his toes yeah but then again if
you were the night manager you would
take that as a sign of flirtation oh
you're picking your toes when I'm here
to fix your TV yeah okay well now that's
another thing see there's things that
people take everybody's idea of what is
flirtation is different right so I think
if you're in your room you're chilling a
dude you're like hey something's wrong
with the TV he comes up and he's being
even a say of that guy the night manager
guy or or the the night manager guys
thinking of media of course if you're a
gay guy who likes sucking on people's
feet and a guy calls you to his room the
first thing you're hoping in your head
oh yeah well also that's not to do in a
launch all over his back right
sub to form watching porn right Hotel
manager fixes TV and something else
right it's not too far down the pipeline
not crazy at all you might have taken
some melatonin the night before still
been a little off in the head
so I think yeah if someone's yeah so
some people they read signs wrong
correct especially if you want the signs
to be a certain thing that's what's
really interesting right and dude that's
what likes that's what like [__] me up
with like rejection and dating and like
that's why I'm like so like I don't hit
on women I just kind of see if they like
come to me because I'm scared because
I'm gonna go into a movie and I saw
Jackass 2.5 in high school with this
girl I thought I was vibing with we saw
in the middle of the day matinee you
know Balling on a budget and we like
held hands during the movie afterwards I
kissed her in front of her car Pontiac
and I was I was geeked and she was
driving she could drive she had one of
those yeah wow yeah so but when I got
home I remember I was so excited I was
unloading the dishwasher
um because I was a chore my mama made me
do and then I got a text I was like hey
I always
don't want to confuse you but I always
just say it's more of a friend
and I and I think by that to this day
damn so now like that's where my
rejection fears come from it's like you
make that move and she's like oh no like
I no I totally saw you just as like a
friend and you're like oh my bad like I
don't I think just the embarrassment
yeah [__] you up
oh yeah I remember I mean when I was
really young my mother rejected me so
much that that kind of stuff really
hangs over onto a lot of relationships
right but I'm trying to think of what
actual girls
uh uh yeah some kids locked me in this
one girl into a closet and they kept
saying like you need to kiss or whatever
right you want a girl huh yeah that's
like the straightest thing you've got oh
it was insane dude so we didn't know
what to do so that was scary they're
like what do you think you didn't know
what to do yeah like you queers better
make out or we're gonna beat the [__]
out of you you know and so I did were
you paying these people to say that to
you good [__] I guess and we both lived
in like the same neighborhood so we had
the same haircut dude so it was like
that was the part that was just [__]
crazy because I didn't know if like
we were both like you didn't like
Scramble for a beanie or something to
cover up her hair I just didn't know if
we were like trans by hair or whatever
like I didn't know what was going on you
know it was like just what if you made
out to turn into one person oh yeah
so that was a lot dude I remember that
and just the fear of having to make out
while people are banging on the door and
threatening to [__] you up if you don't
kiss that's crazy what'd you guys end up
doing kissing I think I don't even
remember I don't know I just remember
being so [__] just scared you know
yeah and then um but yeah as I got older
yeah I think just you know I never got
to be like my buddy would always be the
one who was inviting the girl to the
dance and he always had the girlfriend I
always had to go with like the friend of
the yeah I was always like the wingman
by uh by accident yeah it'd be like my
friend would start talking to a hot girl
and then it's like the two plus ones at
a wedding they hit it off it's like the
guy and the girl both know the people
getting married and then there's just
two random people that are like I'm dead
I used to bang his dad I don't know
there's no correlation yeah I'll never
forget I asked the girl I just posted on
my Instagram the dad asked a girl when I
first moved to LA like one of my first
weekends out my friend's talking to hot
chick I'm just talking to other girl and
I was like oh what do you do for work
and she goes no I was like all right
no is crazy not even n-o-p-e nope yeah
no cool
two letters ruined me that was 2017. I
still think about it I know it's no but
no is crazy bro an unexpected no will
ruin you it'll rock your world it'll
[__] well I think a lot of women I
don't know if they realize like how much
is a man it is it's hard for us to
[__] get up there and put the balls
out there that's why like I command
anybody that does it whether you take an
L or not dude the other day I'm in New
York City right
and thanks to everybody that came out in
New York we had we did like a show in
the round oh in New York we were out in
Westbury New York oh wow and Glennie
balls came out oh nice
um no-nonsense Keith Peterson came out
uh so anyway it was awesome how big was
that it was like maybe 20 200 or 2400
maybe beautiful so it was cool man it
was really and it was just it was great
I would go back there in a heartbeat
um but I do uh yeah I was always the
friend of a friend on the dating thing
and I think a lot of it was just no con
lack of confidence because when I look
uh
it almost makes me like I'll wait for
chicks to ask me out sometimes but I
know that then you end up getting you
don't end up getting sometimes options
of who you want you end up getting
options of Who Wants You Right which
isn't bad right because sometimes it may
be a better path for who Wants You might
be get you exactly where you want to be
right but are you always then is there
some feeling of like oh I'm not asking
who I want okay does it make sense no it
does it does
um I I kind of like if
I kind of like that a little bit because
then they are at least under the
maybe Assumption of like oh this is
Theo's life I know Theo I love Theo oh
he did there's a podcast and he tours a
crazy amount like they know Baseline
level Theo but when you go on like Ryan
I'm not on there I can't get on either
really yeah that makes me feel better
about myself
God I've been on this like 12 [__]
months waiting and just dude Instagram
called Rio 2as and those damn girls I'm
like yo damn traffic dude I don't know
what the [__] happening there's people
who are like valet attendants like the
Beverly Wilshire who are on there it's
insane Biden's on there I think
Life Alert and [__] Raya his two
go-to apps but yeah but I'm not on there
and it's kind of good I think I think
being off the apps is probably helpful
yeah I'm not I'm not on any of them I
just I but it's kind of nice that I
can't get on in a way yeah I just see
like
how people's body movements are without
an app it's like animalistic they're
just like right right right right right
and they're just like looking so much
for like a stimulation it's like I'd
rather something either happen in real
life or somebody kind of come to me
because then they're like hey like I see
what you do I see what you're about
and I like that right versus if you're
on an app you're starting Baseline she's
like what do you do and you're like oh
I'm like to you you're Theo Von you're
so clearly who you are you know exactly
who the [__] you are and then you tell
somebody who's disconnected in this
world and you're like oh I'm a comedian
they're like oh like like what do you do
and you're like oh my God like I like
like just imagine explaining your tour
schedule to somebody who just found out
you did stand up they'd be like wait
like there's so much to unpack so if
somebody already knows like oh you're
always doing your podcast you're always
on the road you're always filming like
they kind of understand they know what
they're signing up for maybe in a sense
and I don't want to sound pretentious or
anything but it does feel like somebody
might have done their research a little
bit yeah you know versus if you're just
on a date and it's just generic like
yeah well if I mean if you don't you
might almost have to get on a blind date
to have somebody because these days you
can look somebody up and see some stuff
about them even though sometimes it's
better not to do it oh yeah I had a girl
tell me uh before date she went on uh
the internet typed in Trevor lost dick
size nothing popped up um
but I'll but I'll tell her it's a it's
12 12.
[Music]
yeah 12 by 12. it is really it's a CM
maybe cm it's a centimeters 12 oh I
don't it's a gross it's 144. yeah
it depends on how crypto is doing let's
be honest but she just she told me that
while we were on the date she's like
yeah I like to look up the guys on dates
with and I looked up like your dick size
just see if anybody like talked about it
wow nobody had
yeah I think they're left speechless
gang bro I haven't at Wayne or when
you're young and having that [__]
piece on you is really it's crazy and
especially if you're so lonesome as a
kid it becomes your only [__] way to
make yourself feel good that's what I
remember a little stress ball I remember
just feeling so horrible about myself
that the only way I can make myself
because it's an explosion of feeling
good it really is a stress ball the
penis is stress ball stressed out touch
it a few times wow I'm unlimited dude I
remember getting scared I was gonna run
out how much I had in me too you know
oh and you know what's crazy you never
really do and then you hit 78 one day
and all this well unless you're the Nero
yeah what do you take for that oh I
think he just [__] Herbalife I think
you just take a nap and then [__]
you know what I'm saying is there an age
you think you'll be done being horny oh
yes 65 probably anybody I think once you
can retire to me if people are real
older and they're [__] to me it seems
like a lot somebody asked me recently if
my dad still [__] I was like I don't
want to know yeah but some days he comes
in a little too calm and I guess all
right
were you playing the back nine or are
you playing the back what are you doing
pops
I've been asking all that dude if he's
doing it I would never ask I would never
ask yeah I think one time I went my
stepdad I I live with this family in
high school and I went with them and uh
the dad and I did a Mardi Gras parade
and he told me that he got a little
recently and it [__] blew my mind
kind of like crazy like I never think I
didn't know but it was just crazy to
hear it what else we got Zach any news
this woman says she's allergic to
running
um a lot of people are giving her [__]
for this she had a reaction trying to
catch a flight oh she got a UTI that's
all that is
the New York
the swelling has swelled I just had a
reaction you'd go back to that dude
God damn wow that was like watching porn
back in the day where like the photo
would load you know percentage-wise
because that that came in out of nowhere
at first I wanted to be like all right
you're being annoying for no reason then
I was like you can be allergic to
anything just not me God
oh there's footage of her running
and it's funny how like people like uh
sorry to cut you off uh document
everything on Tick Tock now like like
there's like in court they're like
watching tick tocks but well here's me
documenting my rash yeah yeah it's like
[__] that's a tick tock yeah okay that
isn't necessarily if you put it to music
or whatever what does she say in this
thing Zach can we see any of this
she was running on a delayed flight and
then made a tick tock about how you can
be allergic to running and this is proof
of that is because she had a reaction to
it
that's not like something I would have
said in like 8th grade PE when they're
like all right run the mile but I'm
allergic once we got on the plane she
started breaking her into hives and this
is what happened last time when her
throat started closing she popped a few
benadryls hoping it would go away but it
didn't
[Music]
no reason
from her doubts that she's allergic to
running thankfully she was fine and it
was just a little drowsy after
what a full circle moment
it's crazy do you think that we're
getting so soft people allergic to
running I think that is the environment
that we're headed into as a species yeah
well I do think that's something that
you could challenge a PE teacher with or
you got to run the mile I'm allergic to
the mile uh what do you mean you're
gonna question what I'm allergic to yeah
just like you're allergic to your wife
where's the last time you saw her
flaming the vegan teacher
but bro that's the problem with every
nobody here's one of the issues with
everything nobody wants to follow what
the kind of basic guidelines are for
everything like there when I was a child
there was a template for everything it
was how you did it you stood for the
Pledge of Allegiance you didn't even
know anything maybe you knew a fireman
maybe your mom and [__] you know was
trying to date a cop or something that's
a most she knew about the military but
you stood for the Pledge of Allegiance
right you like you respected your
questions you didn't question anything
and now we've gotten a place where you
question everything but is it doing us
any good really because all it is is
just watching people fight and now
nobody wants to do any jobs anymore
because they're not respected well also
I think it's the power of the phone too
because like a PE teacher can be like
that's not real you have to run the
[__] mile but then you pull a phone
out and they're like well now I could
get fired for this and they're like oh
all right it's like those videos where
people are like acting crazy like the
Karen type [__] they whenever they see
the phone they either double down and go
even crazier I love when they go crazy
they're like oh hello Facebook
young ass he's on Facebook but they're
always like oh hello everyone who's
watching but you either double down or
you back up and you're like oh I'm so so
dude I saw a guy get kicked off a flight
this is a great story this guy got
kicked off a flight I was coming back
from Hawaii and this dude he was an
older guy and uh this is first class I
say this uh you know once once a year
after all the touring I go to Hawaii
it's like my like [__] chill out
place and on the flight back this guy
first thing goes do you guys have any
vegan options for breakfast like 7 A.M
she goes oh no that's all we have and it
was some scrambled egg and he gets mad
he tosses the menu in the air and I go
this we're about to pop off you can feel
that [__] a little bit of Hulk Hogan
and this could do is like 70 right
next they're playing like just kind of
like ukulele just kind of casual and the
TV screens it's like it's a preset it's
just plays it's like it's a small world
it's just playing and it goes hey can
you turn this music off right and I go
we're really bubbling we're getting to
something good and then they go we can't
turn off the music this is the most
electric thing I've ever seen he pulls
out his iPad and he puts on Stairway to
Heaven by Led Zeppelin on full blast and
he leans over to his wife and goes
they'll never make music like they used
to and then eventually he's playing it
out loud seven minute song in it and
it's to the point where I'm like this is
a good [__] song you know and then
essentially like they gave him a couple
warnings and then uh this like Simone
chick and cop outfit comes in grabs them
by the shoulder and his attitude shifts
like crazy he's like oh I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to and then he turns the
music off and they kick him off he
leaves his wife there but on the way out
on the way out most badass thing he ever
says he goes go on without me you'll be
fine you always are I was like this is
the most I was like what the [__] is
happening this is like the end of a
[__] guilf porn scene but the guy got
escorted and the wife didn't say [__]
the whole time she's like somebody gives
me some fentanyl stop acting out Robert
it was Randy's gonna Randy yeah it was
one of the most electric things damn bro
that's hype when somebody gets thrown
off but his his change was so quick and
it was it was one of those moments where
everyone else on the plane started
looking at him like oh is this we're
about to be in a this a world star
moment yeah I was exciting you ever been
in a and like like a moment like that
where someone's about to start popping
off oh dude when I was last time I was
in Hawaii they had a uh somebody died at
breakfast right
uh so let me think about what happened
so we're at breakfast right because
that's where somebody died at and good
meal to die out every oh I agree
everybody's eating right Magic Johnson
is there really it was a nice hotel
right yeah so same right one tier I take
myself to a nice hotel in Hawaii right
which is a blessing man it's like I work
super hard that's what I do so Magic
Johnson's is there dude and he's
chilling and some dude starts dying you
know and every some people know how to
help people that are dying so I I kind
of jump up and I'm like oh [__] I don't
know anything I'm a comedian yeah so I
sit back down so I'm plugging Bluetooth
ads
so other people go over there and they
put up like just partition around the
dude's table which you can hear him over
there just humping on the dude right
they take the buffet stands and put it
in front closed yeah that's kind of how
they did but then so many people got
over there they even had to move those
so you can kind of see the guy and they
finally get him back up right but then
uh he goes down again and so they're
over there and then it's like he it's a
wrap so everybody's like how long do you
wait how long do you wait till after
somebody's like dead to eat again right
so everybody's kind of like can you get
seconds right there's nobody's like
making a move he's a waiter take his
plate like are you done here do you need
a box or do you need to be in a box what
are we doing here yeah
so it's like what do you so what did
Magic Johnson do it was crazy and I'm
like dude this guy should have done
something right first name imagine or
something yeah or like that you know
make a wish the final thing is like dude
Magic Johnson's here to send you off
yeah that'd be kind of cool that'd be so
cool the last thing you see is like a
couple pineapples and Magic Johnson I'm
gonna assist you to heaven brother
you know and then you don't die and
you're just hanging out and he's like
I'm gonna go to my room now yeah
Kareem's an [__] that's what I've
always heard that's crazy last time I
was in Hawaii uh the week I got there
somebody got their arm chopped off in a
7-Eleven with a machete oh wow yeah
that's crazy that seems like more
Albuquerque type Vibe it really is it's
kind of like also like we get it it's a
personality thing I have to walk around
it would have in your arm I was machete
yeah I get it but uh it was crazy yeah I
met a cool lady from I think Oklahoma
maybe and her daughter she had lost an
arm
um she was a mail truck driver and I met
her and her daughter beautiful ladies
and uh
she had something that happened the mail
truck had fallen over and uh she rolled
over it rolled over on her arm and she
didn't she
um that's crazy yeah she mailed her arm
to Heaven I guess or whatever you know
or whatever however they say it but she
was missing an arm I don't know what
else we got man anything else we wanted
to talk about I'm trying to think
um
how's work been man so you tour you do
you notice that there's other Comics
because you kind of got your start do
you feel like in social media yeah yeah
I started with stand-up but social media
is what kind of like put me in front of
people and then I used the people who
are watching me from digital to be like
hey I also do stand up come to the show
yeah and then just kind of like you know
the first headlining show I did was in
San Diego in like 2017 and like 112
people showed up and I was like oh okay
cool and then I quit my job and I slowly
did one-nighters and then I just kind of
started building with videos and just
and then by throwing myself in the deep
end to headline I have 45 minutes on my
set list I wrote crowd work this was
early on yeah you know how bad you got
to be at that time to be like all right
for the next five minutes uh oh cool
what's your brother's name like I wasn't
ready so I just kind of turned myself in
the deep end just
because I was like you know if I'm gonna
take this leap I gotta do it now you
know because then I can quit my job pay
my rent by doing stand-up and a little
bit of videos and I can just double down
on myself and that was sick [__] I don't
even know almost six years ago yeah but
yeah it's good I'm filming the special
and uh yeah do you know uh the Paramount
in Austin oh yeah July 14th and 15th uh
Saturday's shows are sold out uh we
added a Friday and I think that's almost
sold out but troubleworldcomedy.com but
you're doing like nine shows there right
yeah we're gonna be there I think in
like a week or so holy [__] have you
done that theater before next week yeah
it's great I've done it a few years ago
I haven't done it in a while yeah how
many shows you doing I'm so excited I
think we're doing
nine ten ten we just added another show
what the [__] is that two per night or
is that just like 10 days no it's 10
days I'm going to stay in Austin oh
rolling it up yeah I'm gonna spend some
time over there and try to just see what
I like about the city nice it is I was I
was there on Sunday it's a nice city you
were I do like yeah so on after
Indianapolis oh you'll love this we
filmed at garyvee con with garyvee did a
video there and then on Sunday there was
in Kyle Texas which is 30 minutes from
Austin they tried to break the record
for most people named Kyle in one
location ever and I made that video
about a couple years ago about like guys
named Kyle huh I was like this like
[__] just it just a kid who just
loved punch and dry while drinking
Monsters just like just was a kid who
definitely was neglected by his parents
and huffed ax body spray and then so
they were doing a Kyle meet up
and I was like dude how funny it would
be if I went to this Meetup dressed up
as my Kyle character so he did it I did
that was on Sunday yeah so that's the
video we're working on is that crazy it
was [__] nuts but it's like if it was
at the Kyle fair right so there was like
families and [__] there but there was
also 1700
people named Kyle registered and you
needed 2 300 to break the record they
missed it they missed the record but
dude I'll tell you what I've never seen
dude that many calls we could have
[__] January 6 all over again dog we
could have taken over a [__] Vape
Shop Easy dude it was and what did they
do yeah what was their boost were there
like Kyle dude there was a drywall Booth
where you could duck duck Kyle or
whatever dude I don't even know what the
[__] we were in and out of there pretty
quick
um but there was a drywall Booth where
you could pay five dollars to punch some
drywall
um it was like half families and just
half dudes named Kyle with nothing
better to do it's just crazy to see that
many people named with one name in the
same place it is because they all look
like they were cops they all look like
bring up Kyle
looking
yeah they all kind of look like they
would uh uh you know they had puka shell
necklaces at one point oh yeah and they
they got sunburn easy type of type of
fellow you know it's not like blonde
hair but it's not brown it's kind of
that like yeah typing oh yeah there you
go so there's me right there so if you
go to Kyle Know Your Meme it's just
there's my house right there yeah oh God
yeah
so I made this video like
maybe three or four years ago about a
guy's named Kyle and then so I just was
like this would be such a funny video
it's so stupid if we just went to the
the fair and so we got a video and like
it was very it was fun dude anytime
people see a camera and a microphone
they already get pretty like fired up
but then when Kyle see a camera they're
like this is my chance so dude they're
going wow they let me on stage and I got
to yell a bunch of [__] that's sick dude
I was like it smells like Slim Jims and
broken homes and uh then they were like
you're all right Trevor Wallace yeah it
was fun man so that video will be coming
out later this week but um were you ever
approached by like bar stool or anything
to work with them uh I've done podcasts
there but not like anything to work for
them like no yeah no no no no I never
was I don't know or have any La people
like work there I think it's a lot of
East Coast people I don't know why they
don't have an LA office also
yeah maybe LA's just [__] too [__]
for them dude
but they're good people over there I
know I said whatever how their their
podcast clip stuff you know I think
they're very aware of that but they're
good people everybody I've met over
there is really nice dude Caleb's
awesome uh all the KFC guys oh yeah dude
they crushed it over there I mean they
kind of like you know they've created
some neat shows they got all types of
characters that start to come out of
there I think that's real fascinating
yeah you know I'd love to have sometimes
more like characters to be involved like
in our world and podcasting and stuff
sometimes it's hard to like facilitate
all that though you know I mean it's
literally like a reality show it's like
they just launch careers based on the
employees they work with it's really
smart because people attached to the
personalities instead of the brand it's
like oh we love Glenny balls but in
loving Glenny balls you're loving bar
stool you know yeah it's so much easier
to to get attractive personality than as
a brand so it's really smart to do that
what um
what um what else could we think about
yeah I don't know if I can even think
about anything else did I ever tell you
the story when I first met you
you're eating is the Oxnard improv maybe
I said this in the last pocket we'll
just say anyways but the first time I
met you I I hosted for your show in
Oxnard oh thanks dude and uh this is
like 2015 2016 and you ordered a salad
it was a tuna Sashimi salad with lettuce
in your life I don't want any lettuce
and the lady's like so you want the
salad and you're like I don't want the
lettuce and then you were eating just
raw tuna with your shirt off and you
looked at me and you go it's crazy
anybody can make a baby and I was I was
like such a fan and I was just like
didn't want to overset my boundaries and
I was like yeah man
that is crazy like I didn't I don't want
to like it is crazy man when you think
that anybody could [__] just eat
probably late into somebody else and
[__] get a kid out of them but that's
all that was going through your mind it
was just such a funny just sitting there
eating makes me [__] hard boy it does
thinking about that thank you man yeah
thanks for even checking in while I was
eating dude I mean I was just sitting
there that was fun we've done a lot of
fun shows together we did [__] Red
Banks together and uh yeah dude that was
crazy bro I was losing my mind that
weekend remember really oh well you I
think your flight got in like 30 minutes
before the show but I was like losing my
[__] mind that was crazy it was cold
it was during bizarre it was bizarre
times yeah it was Red Bank people were
wasted oh yeah because it was outside
it's like the first event let alone like
a big name like you was there dog
[__] yeah I saw one guy just throw a
chair at another chair I was like what
are you trying to [__] make less
chairs it was [__] awesome dude that
was a fun weekend die I got to open your
will turn show that that was uh yeah
dude that was great man it was like the
biggest theater that was awesome people
were stoked really at the time yeah I
ended up doing one over the summer that
was outside it was like some stupid like
5 000 thing that was Unreal I wasn't
headlining wait did you do uh Canada
yeah the Outside Lands it was me am I
going there oh and Tom's girl so we we
essentially like open Loosely open for
Tom Segura but it was supposed to be P
Davidson and canceled and then Tom
filled in and they're like all right you
guys are still on the show so you're
doing it outside
let me know how you think it is
damn it's I texted Bobby Bobby did it
too I talked to Bobby Bobby said he
liked it it's it's fun it's just
different it takes a second to get used
to it but like that like big pop is
still there
but it's it's not like as magnetic you
know like electric damn the labs it's
like you know when you watch people vape
and it just dissipates in the air yeah
in a comedy club it gets a little smoky
in there yes yeah let's go up to the
yeah the people are like huh it's not
like you bomb but it's just like people
like huh it's just weird watching
somebody eat funnel cake while you
follow your dreams oh yeah but the
lashes drift up but dude I will say
Edmonton is very like ye like conscious
[__] you'll Crush dude people might even
get closer to the stage if you were like
[__] come here and get a lick of
daddy people would swarm up front [__]
yeah boy like [__] your table come sit
up front [__]
and is it big like can you see everybody
no dude like I honestly like I like it
blew my mind that that was there many
that was their mint I can't talk that
many people were just there like it blew
my mind like 5 000 people just watching
you and you're like just talking it's
crazy damn but yeah I'm excited about it
I think uh yeah it's the only outside
show that I have I think right now also
I was in headlining Tom was so Tom by
the time he got on was a little darker
so we were up there broad daylight but
oh yeah broad daylight dude crazy I mean
there's people there's a lady like
burping a baby in the front room yeah I
like that better breastfeed yeah
God I [__] love so if something's on
a tit near me I'm [__] happy really
oh yeah RCP one I'm next oh how do I
jumped the line oh I want to see I just
want to smell gasoline and [__] watch
something [__] breastfeed boy you
ever had breast milk uh I haven't had a
lot
but you have I probably had a little I
would say you know how can you even not
get something with all the cat with
everything these days there's probably
everything okay everything's cut with
that something dude yeah you can't even
get a pure line of cocaine without being
like
a little bit of [__] lactate
a little bit of breast milk in it
um dude thanks for hanging out today man
dude thanks for having me I uh yeah you
can check out six socks podcasts
back over there sometime and check in
with you guys please do man it's always
fun man people love seeing our chemistry
together yeah same man it's been a blast
over the years man you're so excited to
watch and
um I'm glad that you and I are Buds and
that we have like
you know the ability I can connect it if
I have a question you know and I ask you
always there for me so I appreciate you
yeah dude by any means you called me
recently you're like do people still use
the word Riz and I was like yeah you
could and I looked at the comments on
that video people were like they were
like quoting it like laughing oh good
yeah I'm glad to be your like Millennial
little [__] to the internet yeah I gotta
have that plug-in exactly exactly thank
you bro you're great man thanks for
having me and I mean that about your
audience when I said earlier the best
people yeah man I don't know how we did
it I don't know how we got a part of it
just yeah there's a lot of special
people I think uh you know what you put
out their tracks you know real attracts
real and that's the [__] worst thing
I've ever said in my life but it makes
sense you know we're trying to stay yeah
it's just it's been interesting man but
it is crazy bro I can't even believe
that this many people come out to shows
and you know so I think you're only
getting bigger I think I think I think
uh your name is just like I know like
that you're big when like like people
who have never even seen stand up
anymore like they're just so
disconnected you know like people who
are just so hot that when they don't
look you in the eyes it makes sense uh
and then the one time make eye contact
they're like do you know Theo Bond
you're like yeah this [__] is on
this dude is on
so congrats on that you're gonna do 10
shows at the Paramount Paramount that's
crazy yeah it's excited it's like 13 000
people so it's gonna be crazy well
thanks Trevor I appreciate it man and
thanks for spending time dude uh Trevor
Wallace will share all of his socials
and everything
Amen brother best of luck I'll see you
out there I'll see you on the date naps
hell yeah yeah trying to date each other
all right
[Music]
I can feel
it in my bones
it's gonna take